Can anyone play the guy with walls?
Wait what?
We can't, we can't, we can't.
Okay, none of us know this?
I think he's a Caesar character.
We are so fucked.
I wanted to play the Raichi guy.
His gun's based.
Oh yeah, that's the wall guy.
Hey guys, hey everybody.
I'm live right now by the way.
I'm live right now.
I go be...
Guys, listen to me.
This is the strat.
First round you buy one thing.
And then next round if you don't have enough money for armor, sell whatever you bought and buy armor.
Okay, because I bought damage.
It's like on the right side.
It's just armor.
Press B, press B, sure.
Yeah, press B.
I bought damage.
Why do I go A or B?
I bought damage too.
I'm B.
I put turrets on B.
It's not A.
Someone needs to do mid.
Nobody's looking at mid.
We don't need mid.
We need A or B.
What if they fucking rush mid?
We're getting walled.
They put a wall on A.
They're going A.
Okay, okay.
These guys have strats.
Okay, yeah, that's what I'm...
Oh, me already.
What?
Dude, I got fucking run down.
Yeah, I double...
Oh.
Okay.
He's looking at me with an auto sniper.
This is a mess already.
We don't...
They're all point.
I got one.
One guy's low.
Okay.
They planted the bomb.
I got one.
I got one on the ground.
Oh my god.
They're behind me.
Behind me.
Right here.
It's a 2v2 situation.
Yeah, but we...
I am okay right now.
1v2.
Last guy.
He fused.
I'm not...
I'm not res...
Okay.
Fuck you guys.
Yeah, you fucking crawl on the floor there.
All right.
For those who don't know, for in my chat, we just started tournament.
It was...
There was no breaks.
We just went straight in.
Let's go next.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Who's that guy with free kills?
I don't know, man.
Who is that?
Wow.
Is that the top 20 Overwatch player?
Wait.
How do you know about that?
What the fuck?
Because I was like, who the fuck is this guy that's on our team?
I feel like he's top 20.
Can I go next?
Can I actually support him?
I can shield and shit.
I'm out.
Okay.
I don't know what's my character, Daz.
I don't even know what your character...
What are you playing?
Press F1.
Press F1 and leave.
Read between rounds.
I don't know what's my character, Daz.
This is going great.
We're doing great, guys.
We're doing great.
I need to fix my game.
There's no breaks.
Oh yeah.
They're here.
They're testing us.
They're going B now because A didn't work.
Yeah.
They know the best player is at A.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I was on A.
I'm not peeking.
No.
I'm talking about the actual best player.
Whoa.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm dying.
IPN's dead.
We got to help him.
I'm going to rez IPN.
I'm looking.
I'm looking here.
Help me.
I put them on the ground.
Thank you.
And we didn't thirst him though.
I was reloading.
I can bullhack him too.
I'm looking at the side here.
I'm not in a good position.
I think they're rotating right now.
Yeah.
They did.
They rotated.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh no.
There's one more.
One more.
No.
They're just staying.
They're staying.
They're staying?
Okay.
I'm just going to put turrets back then.
I want to play solo A.
Yeah.
They might be rotating.
Wait.
They're going B.
They're back in B.
Wait?
What?
Oh.
They baited.
You want to play retake?
You got this, right?
Yeah.
You can play retake.
We got one down.
Nothing left.
Yeah.
We're coming back.
One stop left.
One stop left ramp.
Sorry.
Left.
Ready?
Yeah.
I'm heading over.
I might die doing this.
Oh, there's three guys here!
There's three guys here!
Four guys here!
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Oh my god, what happened?
That shit blinds me when I go through it, man!
I got one!
Ming's low, Ming's low.
Next behind you.
Yeah!
Nice!
One more, one more, one more, one more.
No, no, it's all dead.
Wait, yeah, we natural know.
Oh, wait, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm...
No!
I carry!
Okay, okay, okay.
You have to use your peeker's advantage, bro.
Yeah!
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good.
That's on me.
Okay, I still don't have armor.
I went in first!
Why am I getting fucked up when I went in first?
I was talking about next.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so now buy the thing that tells you to buy.
I'm buying, I refunded some shit.
I refunded something for it.
Don't buy heavy shield.
Buy the light regen shield.
Wait, don't buy heavy shield?
Why not?
But it's heavy.
Because it doesn't regen.
Oh.
Yeah, but I'm gonna die anyway.
I'm not gonna live long enough to regen.
Guys, I'm gonna hold mid.
You see the back out?
I can like, Q you.
Like, just kill the snipers.
I can also flash.
They're mid.
I'm gonna come point mid.
Yeah, I see them.
They're KO-knifing me.
KO-knifing on me.
I've been spotted.
I'm smoking.
Ow.
They got mid.
They're close mid.
They smoked.
Mid to A.
Mid to A again.
Oh, they're here.
Okay.
I'm going back.
Mid to A again.
I'm coming to you guys.
Next night, I'm coming to you.
I'm gonna anchor, just in case they come back.
I downed one.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
Good job.
I'm gonna flank.
They're rezzing him, though.
Okay.
Throw a nade.
Guy invisible on point.
I kind of fucked him up.
I'm gonna do something dumb.
You guys wanna push?
I can flash it.
Flashing?
Yeah.
Fuck.
Wait.
I got one.
One on point.
In the corner.
Invisible.
Oh, I'm down.
Oh, I'm here.
Oh, I was here.
Oh, fuck.
I was trying to throw a set.
We went in one by one.
We need more on A, I think.
More on A.
We had two on B.
I was on mid.
Oh, okay.
I'm rezzing back and forth.
But the thing is, if you get a knock, you gotta have nades.
Yeah, dude.
Have a nade.
I'm back.
Yeah, yeah.
Just nade him.
That's true, I have nades.
Oh my god.
Because I flashed all of them.
I've been called but no one's there.
I have my turret.
I have my ult.
I can use my ult for take back.
What does your ult do?
My ult... I throw a fucking turret.
Oh yeah, it's ult-y.
Yeah, yeah.
I can use my ult for take back here.
It's not B.
Oh, it's mid.
Yeah, I see them.
I'm gonna throw my turret right now!
I'm gonna do it!
I'm behind him.
Doki, run.
Doki, there's a whole team on you.
I know, I know.
That's why I threw my turret.
Because I was scared.
They're fucking killing my turret.
He's dead.
My turret died instantly.
They're pushing Doki.
Someone's pushing Doki.
He's low, he's low, he's low, he's low!
They're all low as fuck.
They're all so low!
Go, go, go.
Push, push, push.
They're all blind.
I'm low, they're all low.
I threw my grenade there.
How long was this fucking ult last?
My ult is down.
I'm down, I'm down, I knocked one.
I got it.
There's a sniper behind.
There's two more.
Nice.
One more on the right side.
I'm pushing now.
I'm giving a fuck.
Yeah, yeah.
Go crazy.
Oh shit, go crazy!
I'm blind.
I can't see anything.
I'm ulting you.
I'm going crazy by crazy.
I mean, I'm not hitting anything.
I think our 200 ping is actually doing stuff right now.
Oh my god, pinged it!
Okay, if you get a full send, just tell me how old you are.
It's like...
Yeah, I did say it.
I did say it.
Yeah, but I didn't...
Okay.
Okay guys, calm down.
Everyone calm down.
By the way, just so you guys know, defense is harder than attack.
Defense is harder?
Because in attack you can just 5v1.
Yeah, in attack you can just storm.
Wait, on this map?
I don't know.
I don't remember this.
Guys, I have my... I'm awake.
I'm a professional.
I'm professional.
I'm awake right now.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm predicting a B push.
Yeah, but you don't even... Sherwood, do you know what your ult does?
It's...
He doesn't need to know.
He shoots him.
I'm KJ ult.
Okay.
He's KJ ult.
It's not B.
It's not mid either.
It's an A push.
I see.
I'm rotating.
Okay, fine.
I have my grenade pre-caught.
They're mid, mid, mid, mid, mid, mid.
Oh, they're mid?
Okay.
Ooh, mid, mid, mid.
Ooh, next.
Don't die, next.
No, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
I went out A though.
Yeah, they're also nading me from mid.
They crossed from mid.
They crossed from mid to A.
Mid to A.
Yeah, mid to A.
Okay, I'm going back to you then.
I'm fucking... They're wall hacking me.
Cheating, cheating.
Oh my God, it's as if this...
They're smoking the point, man.
I'm walling.
Got you.
I got one.
I'm ulting A.
Oh, he's coming.
One more, one more, one more.
One more site, one more site.
Hello, site.
Three, four, three, four.
We got two.
Look at the wall hack.
Yeah, we're going, we're going.
I'm flashing up.
We got another.
I knocked him.
I fixed him.
Last guy, last guy, last guy!
I'm waiting.
There you go.
Dead.
I used KJ ult.
Yeah!
I used me KJ ult.
Nice KJ.
I have another turret for take back again.
It says I can teleport between my things.
How do I do that?
I don't know.
I never played that.
I'm not KJ, I'm your chamber.
None of us play those.
No, I'm chamber and killjoy.
It's not me again.
It says my awakening lets me teleport.
They're going mid.
They're wall hacking me.
I'm slowed.
Throwing grenade out.
I'm gonna throw my turret out.
I'm gonna do it.
Nade out.
Wait, actually no.
Never mind.
I'm not gonna do it.
I realized they rotated.
They're on A.
Smoke's on A.
Terrible smoke on A.
I'm looking at...
One's on A right now.
Inside.
I'm throwing my turret.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do something fucking crazy.
Go cat, go!
All three push up.
What the fuck?
They're one.
No!
There's a sniper right here.
Half HP.
I didn't see him.
Oh, I fucked up.
I lost the ramp.
Oh my god, I even used my turret cat.
Oh my god, Nex, you got this.
I have a semi-auto weapon.
So I can't hold ramp if they three man me.
You want me to hold it?
No, they're not.
Okay, I'll play closer to you, Surfer.
I need to turn Surfer down, apparently.
Burn me down?
Yeah, you're too loud.
What if me and Nex is flanked?
I'm full support.
I always flank.
I just check if it's B, and if it's not, I flank on A.
I think I should sell this, and then go for...
What is this?
I think if you thirst...
Q.
When you thirst, do you get ult charge?
Like thirst somebody's kill?
Because I got my turret so fast.
Probably.
So I guess it's just good to thirst, in general.
Do you still want me to smoke this?
I thirst as soon as I can.
Yeah, I thirst too, but I got my turret so fast there.
No one B again.
Mid again.
They're just doing A all the time.
Mid, mid.
I saw someone in mid.
Too mid.
It's always A.
Yeah, it's just always A.
I think they just know it works.
I'll play closer to you, Surfer.
Yeah, yeah.
I got spotted, so they know I'm here.
Smoking him.
Wait, someone's close.
Oh yeah, one right here.
On point, on point, on A point.
Oh, I see, I see somebody on me.
Smoke.
Right here, right here.
The sniper's low.
One down, one down.
Fire my gun.
I'm blind.
What the hell is happening?
I'm dying too.
It's fine, I can rest my soul.
They're pushing the ramp.
Yeah, they fucking killed me from the ramp.
I'm pushing top right.
I'm maybe resable up here.
I'm ramping.
One high.
One more on high.
He's right above you, I'm pushing with you.
I'm not there, I can't climb this wall.
I thought I could paper the wall.
My SMG looking ass cannot handle this shit on the fucking ramp, bro.
Alright, here we go.
What does damage-rad ratio mean?
I don't know.
I'm gonna put that because it looked cool.
I bought it because it looked cool.
It's a string shield damage-rad plus 25%.
I have no idea.
That's your stream.
Oh, damage-rad!
Okay, yeah, I bought that shit.
That's good shit.
I didn't say red.
If they all come here, let's make a play, okay?
You back out and I'll flash it and I'll ult you.
This is such a close game.
It's not B, they're going...
Oh yeah, nevermind.
It is B.
There's a lot B here.
Okay, I have my turrets back there.
I need help.
I see mid.
I'm flashing.
Mid's coming in too.
They smoked mid.
They smoked mid and I'm a little paper boy.
We're stacking this shit.
They're here.
Behind you guys.
I have HP.
They're all here.
My turrets.
Where we died?
Oh, this is going to be awkward.
They figured out my spread, guys.
I ulted.
I'm healing myself.
I'm doing shit.
I'm doing shit to them.
I'm coming over.
I saw a name.
I'm blind as a bat.
Where are they?
I think they're resing right here.
Wait, they got me revealed.
Oh my god, he's one shot.
Oh no.
No.
There's three and there's no way.
Guys, I think the way to play this game is like...
Oh, we switched.
Never mind.
I don't even know how to play this girl.
In attack.
I think I'll play the flying woman.
How did they come behind us next?
I don't know how that happened to you.
Yes, I was so fast.
They probably used the paper.
Oh, that's true.
They used the paper for him.
Pick a smoke grenade.
I'm gonna get a deagle too.
What's the smoke grenade?
I didn't get it.
I have frag grenades and heal grenade.
What's the point of...
Why plant the bomb when you can just kill them?
Yeah, but how do you know we're gonna kill them?
How do you...
That's the thing.
If you plant the bomb, we're sitting ducks, you know?
We just kill them.
We just leave the bomb in spawn.
Let's just leave it.
Who wants the bomb?
I shouldn't be the bomb carrier.
I can.
I'll play full support.
Let's go B.
Let's do a wall.
Anywhere.
I have my slow thing.
I should use my wall.
You have abilities, Sherpa.
Diagonal.
Preferable.
I got spotted.
We got spotted, by the way.
They scanned us.
One's close.
I hit them.
I slowed them.
Is that our wall or theirs?
It's ours.
They're in that corner thing.
I got hit by it.
Do you want to...
We killed them.
What the fuck?
They're in the window there.
I'm beaming them in the window.
Oh, shit.
I got fragged.
They're on the ramp here.
I'm my ping.
I beamed them in the ramp.
One down.
Above us.
I'm throwing nades.
I'm dead to a nade.
Two here.
He's one.
No.
That guy was one.
I got one guy.
That was one.
He's pushing.
Nice.
I got an alpha.
He's on me up top.
I'm dead.
It's a 1v1.
We got the bomb though.
You can stall it.
I'm dead.
You got this.
My gun is not built for close quarters.
Guys, I don't...
I did not expect my two players to just sit there and get shot in the face when I said they're up top.
You said he's up top and I died in the same second you said he was up top.
I had no chance to react.
To be fair, you guys should not have been rezzing when there was just one person left.
He just rezzed me.
No, it was two.
Now you need to sell and buy armor.
I have to sell?
Yeah.
Now, you're reaching.
We did the same thing, but we do it faster.
Don't get stuck behind.
Let's run all the way up here.
Let's get control of this upper part.
They're going to scout us out.
Can we play a little further back?
We found a way to use the scan.
Don't just stun.
I'm just going to be paper.
I'm on the wall.
Me too.
Paper Mario.
How long do you want to use stun?
It takes like six seconds.
I've been spotted.
Maybe you shouldn't have been there during the paper Mario.
I don't know how long that should have fucking stuck.
Let's go.
You can move with the Bloodhound Scan.
I'm going A.
No, he's faking.
Let him fake.
Oh shit.
Me and Nex are also faking.
I fucked up guys.
Okay, sure.
For me, don't fake.
Maybe don't fake.
I was trying to build my wall and got flanked.
I slowed him.
I'm fucked here guys.
I'm planting the bomb.
I threw a nade there behind.
I hit somebody with my nade.
No one's covering you?
No one is.
I'm trying but I thought he said attack was easier.
Behind us.
What the fuck happened?
How many rounds is this to?
Let's try A this time.
We have time to re-establish.
We have time.
We can re-establish.
Let's go A.
Let's do something together.
You mean together?
If we do something together, then we can win.
Okay.
That sounds good.
That was my ult dude.
Oh my god dude.
It's the super uber.
It's the metro wall.
I only played this shit in the deathmatch mode.
Oh my god.
Listen, if you use your wall and then you use your ult, I think you get wallhack through your wall.
And it blocks bullets it said.
Nice.
Cool.
Yeah.
Your ult blocks bullets.
Only your ult does.
Your ping with Z by the way.
They got fucking lasers.
They got lasers.
Chill, chill.
We're gonna go flank.
Okay.
We're not really looking at our flanks right now.
Not gonna lie.
I'm looking at our flank.
I'm gonna look at our flank.
Let's turn around.
Let's fucking just go through mid to B.
No, no, no.
Sit right here and then go A again.
Cause I have my wall.
You've been spotted.
It's fine.
There's a Queen on there.
A bear is scouting.
The bear knows where we're at now.
The bear is still scouting.
Nobody shot the bear.
I shot the bear.
It's not that easy.
Calm down.
He's so big.
What do you mean he's not?
Okay.
I'm gonna put this in here.
That's my slow.
Everyone chill.
We have 55 seconds.
I can build another wall A.
Wait, wait, wait.
The ice is insane.
I'm building another wall A.
I'm gonna cut all the people off in mid.
We're going A.
They know that we've been spotted.
We've been spotted.
We've been spotted for 24 hours.
Go, go, go.
Kill the guy on the ramp.
Oh my god.
You're fucking body blocking me.
I didn't think you would walk backwards.
Where's the ramp?
We're a fucking mess, guys.
I killed one.
Oh my god.
I have to reload.
I said push A and no one pushed.
No one pushed.
And then I body blocked you.
That's two with me.
Wait.
Can I call?
Yes, please.
Okay.
Let me call.
Yeah, I don't trust RPR's captain anymore.
We're gonna go A, but don't...
Stay with me.
Go further back.
Don't get spotted.
The moment we execute, just go in as fast as you can.
It doesn't matter.
The longer we take, they're gonna...
I feel like we should just run in instant instead of waiting.
Yeah, that's what...
Fuck the skin.
Fuck you.
I'm not gonna call then.
If you're gonna call, I'm not calling.
All I'm saying is...
Every single time we've waited, they've all just scanned and then ran out.
Okay, now they know because they used the beer.
Just push.
There's fucking one guy.
I'm pushing.
Oh my god.
They grenaded.
Okay.
All right.
That's why you wait.
You guys didn't want to push.
Just push.
I'm pushing.
I'm smoking the bomb.
Go put the bomb.
Oh, there's so much stuff going on.
I can't see anything.
There's so much stuff going on.
I'm fucking needing.
Smoking that off.
I can't see anything.
We're running through mid.
Run that guy.
Run him down.
There's one guy here.
He's one.
I can't see.
There's three of them.
One more.
Help me.
Behind you.
There's two.
There's two behind.
There's two here.
Oh, they...
Guys, I think they're more coordinated.
I think...
Also, when we push, we don't have to all go through the same corridor.
Listen to me.
They have set-ups to scout us out.
They have scanners.
I think that's why you wait.
They're always going to scan us.
The guy on B has a long cooldown.
That's why I'm...
Dude, I'm not calling.
He gave up.
Bro, let's listen to IP and I feel like he knows what he's doing.
All right.
I'm waiting.
I thought you said defense was hardy.
You don't get to speak.
I feel like attack was hardy.
Okay, what are we doing, IGEL?
I feel like this is not even the hardest thing.
Just play on B.
Stand here.
Stand where our PR is.
Stay here for at least four seconds.
We're staying here.
This is very close.
We can actually execute fast.
We're so far back.
Okay, don't worry.
I'm coming over then.
Oh shit, they pushed us.
We're so far back!
The waiting strat worked.
They're cheating at this point.
We can re-escalate on A.
Play as a ball.
They can't do anything when we push as a five man.
Am I carrying the ball?
Go A.
We're coming over.
Mid!
Kill the bear.
I almost killed someone.
Maybe we can execute faster.
I have ulti.
I'm looking at our backs.
I'm checking flanks.
Mid to B?
Yeah, let's do that.
I'm wall hacking.
Push, push, push.
I can ulti if you...
Oh, I got two!
I got two!
I got two on me!
Okay, this is free.
This is free.
Bomb down.
Putting the bomb.
Yeah, I hit a lot of people there.
I post plant.
Oh, I got hit.
Knocked.
But we knocked one.
I'm killing you, Arpa.
Oh, there's two here to stop.
There's two right here.
There's one on the corner.
Yeah.
Is someone on me?
I killed the robot.
There's two on top.
Three V2.
It's fine.
I'm gonna awaken.
Oh, no.
You are not awakening.
The heat on.
Jokes over your dead.
Guys, I think this team is...
Okay, but I feel like...
Better.
I feel like if we did this earlier, instead of fucking yapping 24-7, we would actually have a chance in attack.
I can't.
Oh, hey, I'm second top fragger.
That's... Hello?
I'm second!
I feel like we need to dock here and we continue.
Hey, guys, I feel like ping...
Oh, wait, no.
Next... Never mind.
Next is you.
Yeah.
Guys, I had 11 knocked.
Yeah, but you didn't finish them!
And the one...
I'm a DMR player.
How can I just look at the chat?
So, wait.
Is this like...
We play one map only?
Yeah, only one match per team.
Yeah, and then we play a different team.
Yeah, we fucking suck.
We need to reconsider our life choices right here.
Guys, RPR, I thought you said you're gonna make a team that's gonna win this.
Like, what was...
You can't win if people don't use the map.
You...
You gaslit me into joining this team.
We did listen and then the guy just ran it down mid and shot us.
Listen...
You're not...
You're uncoachable.
Like, I can't help you.
I'm literally... That was second fragger!
You can't say that!
And what did that do for us?
That what I do?
We got like 4-9!
Or 5-9.
I don't even know.
I think we need to put Surefire on sniper rifle.
He was on sniper this entire time!
I'm on DMR.
No, it doesn't.
If you hit headshot, boom, dead.
Yeah, but if you miss, then you're useless for 5 minutes.
That's so true.
Don't miss!
Don't miss, hello?
Unbelievable.
This guy's a level 30, bro.
Not fair.
Bro, you could've grinded this game whenever!
I'm the highest level in here!
What are you talking about?
I'm level 5.
He's level 5!
Why aren't you level 30?
Why didn't you grind this game, RPR?
Because I'm not captain.
I'm not captain and I have a life outside of...
No, you don't.
Yes, I do.
I can stream other things.
Okay, how do we literally destroy it?
I don't...
What do you mean?
We don't have a room code yet.
Yeah, we're not gonna go in for a while.
We gotta go practice now.
And make a custom room!
Leave and make a custom.
There's a 30 minute break!
There's a 30 minute break?!
We lost too fast, Donkey!
We lost too fast!
We do need that 30 minutes.
The next game for you guys starts at 3 PM EST, alright?
We'll get you 30 minutes before then, alright?
Wait, wait, how many games do we have?
So...
You guys are scheduled for...
1, 2, 3 games.
You will end off at 3 PM EST.
Oh, okay, I was gonna be like...
Holy shit, I have to leave at 3 PM EST.
We're gonna try to see if we can end you off a little earlier.
We'll end the chat off a little earlier, as it seems.
Okay, so what's the strat, RPR?
Okay, can I ask you a question?
Can I ask something?
How many in here has played either CS or Valorant?
At a high level.
I got to Radiant.
Huh?
I'm a CS surf professional.
I got to Radiant once.
Okay, so it's the same concept of baiting out fucking utility, right?
They're gonna use scan, the bear is like a fucking Sova drone, just kill it, and then...
They're gonna re-rotate all the time.
It's about playing the re-rotation all the time.
You bait utility, you try to make them to rotate, and then you can just...
By holding it together, if one of them peeks and you know if he caught, you can literally run him down.
Or you can choose to just re-rotate another place.
It's about map coverage.
You play the information game, and then once you get it, you can execute.
But they don't have...
Valorant sucks.
Yeah, but they don't have unlimited utility.
That's why you bait it out.
We have like two minutes, three minutes or something.
That's why you play hard, you use the scan, and then if we go, let's say, we used all the utilities on us, right?
That's why we pressure mid or B, and then we can just execute A afterwards, because they used everything.
But that doesn't matter.
If five people just cause five different things.
Who's gonna IGL?
You IGL.
I'm not!
It's over.
When you say people don't listen to you, it's literally just Surefour.
Actually, if you look at the recording, when he said, okay, go A, I was the only one on top of him when you three were jerking off in a corner.
I was getting shocked!
Because even on ramp, I don't know if you remember, when three people just ran me and you down, we couldn't do anything.
Because even if you trade, you're still knocked.
I also had a semi-auto weapon.
But you know what I mean, though.
The only way for us to stop is to use utility.
Or, nade.
If you get a knock, toss a frag grenade on top of it.
Can we put this into...
Let's add AI.
To here.
What?
Let's practice with AI.
Yeah, we also don't have the right nades equipped, by the way.
They use the wind nades, smoke nades, slow nades.
I didn't know those exist.
We need to use...
I think frag grenade and heal nade are the best.
I feel like every team in this tournament is a Valorant team, except for us.
We are...
Yeah, pretty much.
Can we not make excuses?
We are not equipped for this.
I'm starting this custom game we're practicing.
Some players are not ready.
Maybe we should have done this before the tournament.
Yeah, RPI.
Yeah.
You're looking at me like it's my fault.
You're the captain.
Like, even if I said, maybe you guys are not ready.
You guys want to practice?
You'd be like, nah, I don't have the time to practice, guys.
I played the game.
We are also a better defender team, just because it requires less coordination on the defense.
It's all about the frags.
The thing is, we got to capitalize on damage.
Like, if we get a knock or something, we have to do something.
Even if I call flashes, if I flash someone, just fucking go in, please.
It's like, if you go one by one, it's just over.
I did that and I died, by the way.
I'm sorry.
Apparently, we need the painter girl.
She's called Madalena.
Painter?
Which one is that?
Painter.
She paints.
Which one was that?
I don't know.
What does she look like?
Is it a glasses girl?
I'm Michelle.
Madalena or some shit.
What?
I've equipped a wind grenade and a slow grenade.
I feel like they fucked us with those.
I forgot the change.
I have a telltale grenade.
What is a telltale grenade?
Wind grenade is like, to slow down pushes.
So it's really good for defense.
I think it tells.
Oh, is it like a scouter?
Maybe.
I guess we just practice YouTube.
Okay, apparently the Madalena is a DMR that has a lot of damage.
She has goo that slows everyone.
And she's OP as fuck.
That's what chat is telling me.
Okay, so who is going to play her?
Who is the player?
I want to do sword girl more.
Not me.
It's not B.
I can swap.
I can play the goo girl.
We just won't have his.
I don't feel like snipers work in this game.
I mean these are bots though.
Yeah, it's like...
We're fucking them up.
Wow, look at these bots.
Guys, they're executing.
We gotta figure out who's playing who and who's throwing nades where.
That's literally all we gotta figure out.
I'm not sure how we're doing it against the bots.
Among us.
There's also an interceptor nade which apparently blocks all other nades.
It's like...
That's what we need for attacks.
Basically.
Interceptor nade.
It's also good for defense too.
Because they execute with flash and smokes.
Oh.
I put my spirit.
Okay, I expect you guys to do all the grenade stuff.
My brain is too small for that.
I don't know how to use my abilities.
Frag grenade is only good if we get a knock to finish from distance.
That's why I'll be the frag grenade to make sure we get our knocks.
I feel like I set the difficulty of this AI to piss low or something.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean it's AI.
AI is always not good.
Don't say that.
I played against AI in ranked and they were crazy.
You don't even know which one is AI and which one isn't.
Yeah you do.
How do you know?
What would the names be?
It's like two words in the world like capitalized.
Like celestial wind or some shit.
I think...
Wait, can I end this match?
And we can make AI harder?
Alright.
Surrender.
I can't believe that we're surrendering to AI.
We're practicing.
This is a good game.
This is in the name of practice.
Apparently these are level 1 AIs.
Can we surrender?
It said in the next round it will start.
We just bone rush it and then just kill all of them.
I'm just gonna bone rush.
Oh yeah, the wallhack that next has is only for you next.
Yeah, I know.
That's why I always call it out if I see people or not.
They're all made up here.
We should do it.
Alright, kill all of them so we can surrender.
We should use next as our little scouter.
Yeah, yeah.
Dude, this wind nade is so fucking annoying.
That's my wind nade, better.
It's so annoying.
Look, I just nade it.
It's fine.
Here's a slow nade too, guys.
Thanks.
Yay!
Oh, the slow nade doesn't slow us.
It's just them.
Yeah, it should.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
I think we literally just lost on fucking nades when you think about it.
Yeah, 100%.
I thought we were... oh, they're gonna surrender.
Alright.
Wait, how do you ping in this game?
Z.
Guys, why'd you surrender?
We were winning.
Team MVP!
No!
She's crying!
Yo.
I'm gonna go here.
AI difficulty, super AI.
Holy shit.
That's the rank AI you've been fighting all along!
Guys, I feel like we should...
We should practice attack.
Because we suck in attack.
Let's go attack.
Okay.
Goodbye, AI bot 4.
Trifor, come to attack.
He wants to play with the bots.
I think he's AFK.
I'll practice defend.
This is gonna help our team coordination!
Trifor!
We need to.
There we go.
Fuck.
I tried to swap.
Imagine we're just...
We're trying to practice and this guy's just taking us down one by one.
We're all like...
Yeah.
That's human element.
Is this... oh, Madelina.
Okay, I see Madelina.
What am I... what am I playing?
I was playing...
What do I get to get rid of the other names?
Trifor took my character, bro.
What was your character?
This one.
Meredith.
She's hot, so I'll play her.
What the fuck?
It's all about team comp!
It's not about the hotness right now!
Don't give a fuck.
Scan knife?
Okay, I'll play the scan knife, bitch.
Fine.
She's got a fat ass too.
What?
She's got the KO knife.
Wait, don't take frag grenade.
Slow grenade.
Oh, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
I forgot to swap my util, because you do it every time.
I have a sniper rifle.
Oh, you went for Kanami?
She's good.
I like her.
Why did you say it like that?
Yeah, it's a little creepy.
She's not like her.
That's a little creepy.
She's hot.
Okay, how do we... so how are we coordinating this?
I can look at my ass.
But the bots won't use nades though, so like what are we gonna practice?
I guess our aim?
True.
Okay, but we can at least talk about like what we wanna do, you know?
And set up like a remote plan, like a default?
I will shoot my recon shorts and maybe shoot someone in head.
Okay.
I will just go like look middle a little bit and throw a knife over there.
Whoa.
Guys, I just scanned on point.
She's got a turret.
What the fuck?
Yeah, that bot's got a turret.
Oh my god, they're doing movement stuff.
I missed everybody.
Guys, these bots are crazy.
What the fuck?
You got destroyed.
These bots are crazy.
Guys, we didn't practice the take at all.
Oh shit.
Okay, you're right, you're right, you're right.
These bots are crazy.
Shoot in the head.
Shoot in the head, sure.
You're right, these bots are crazy.
They're coming back.
Oh no.
Oh, wait, not...
This sniper sucks in this game.
I can't tell if it's fucking hit scan or projectile.
I think we need to find someone for sure for that they can play.
Nah, I can play once.
I don't know how to play.
I like the DMR characters, they just suck at close range.
Mmm...
DMR characters are good apparently because they have good abilities.
Yeah, but they just suck at close range.
So what do you want to play?
Whatever.
So play DMR then.
Whatever we...
That was the plan.
What?
Well, they just don't shoot as fast, that's why.
Well, it's...
They also have spread when you shift.
Like a little bit.
What are these AI thinking, dude?
The absolute best.
No one's up there.
A is clear.
I got one.
I'm pushing mid.
I'm sorry,
I missed every shot.
I fuck him up.
I fuck up the mail character.
I'm WESing.
Got one down.
We got the WES.
I am planting.
I'm getting flanked.
I'm holding high ground for you.
I think they rez.
The guy killed.
Holy shit, they can do that?
Yeah, the bots are strong.
Oh my gosh, I see them.
They're low as fuck.
Two on next.
Down one.
Down one of the bots.
Whoa!
Last guy's here.
Swear.
He's WESing.
One HP.
Oh my god, I've been fucking with the DMR.
We're winning against bots.
I'm so proud of us.
Maybe DMR is the play.
Oh my god, look at my skin.
Just look behind me.
I'm not gonna look.
I will not.
I will not look.
You got paid me to look.
In your pervertedness.
You should look.
You need to pay me to look.
I'm gonna pay you to look at this.
We're all heading to mid.
We were all heading to B.
I'm in B.
Oh my god.
You got it.
I'm already at A.
I'm gonna knife mid.
Let's go mid.
Mid, he's got the turret.
Shoot them.
Oh wait, there's one more.
There's one on the high ground.
I'm shooting a donkey bird.
There's 7-2 on him.
This thing actually doesn't fucking work.
I'm crawling.
Wait, look at my... oh my god.
I need help.
I'm resing.
I'm resing too.
Help me.
Okay, give me a sec.
And you said nade was not important.
I'm resing.
I fucking used that nade to save your life.
Nevermind.
I did not save my own life.
I literally resed you.
Okay, I'm not resing this guy again.
Why should I res you?
This is a fucking AI match.
Because you would have lost without me.
Where does my ult go?
Lavin creates a stealth zone and becomes invisible.
You literally have to...
You're literally bottom fragger.
I can go invisible in this.
Yeah, look at his angle.
Run behind me.
Follow me.
Where?
Okay.
Do you see it?
What?
Dude, the skirt is going up.
You see our fucking cheeks?
It's crazy.
Guys, I got fucking demolished, but I ain't but fucking turrets in mid.
Banning.
Smoking.
Oh.
My staking is going over.
I hit them.
Holy shit!
That's a lot of people.
Oh my god.
There's a lot of people there.
You need my goo?
Nice.
Okay, I'm coming.
There.
Big come.
Huh?
All three are there.
They're low.
One down.
One.
They're high ground.
I'm going here.
Yay!
They're all 1 HP.
Big flank!
Okay, the paint lady is kind of strong.
Okay, this lady is insane.
Yes?
You can flash teammates?
Yes, you can.
I can flash me in one game.
Yeah, you can.
You can.
You can 100% flash teammates.
Wait, this...
Did you just not trust me?
Or what's the problem here?
Who are you telling that to?
I was just reconfirming what you said.
Because someone else didn't trust me.
No, Trifor.
Trifor, why don't you trust RPR?
RPR is a victim.
What?
I am a victim right now.
I literally am a victim right now.
What the fuck?
It's not even me.
Don't worry about it.
It's like victim complex.
No, it's not a victim complex at all.
I'm fine.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Why did you guys wind grenade in your face?
Oh, there's people on me.
All three.
All three are here.
I'm with you.
I'm throwing this one over there.
Okay.
There was a sniper over there.
Wow!
I'm dead.
Guys, B is dead.
Bro, what the fuck are you doing?
You didn't say it was more than one.
I said they were all down there.
Oh.
Why is he losing to AI, you fucking disgrace?
It's fine, bro.
We'll save this shit.
Don't worry, I got it.
All headshots.
Guys, shoot the little turrets as well.
Like, what are we doing?
None of us are taking this seriously right now against the AI match.
We're just fragging.
We're just practicing our aim.
We're not even practicing teamwork.
We're practicing something's being practiced.
Like, this character is good.
We should do an A execute.
Through mid, out, IV, through connector.
Who has the smoke?
Wait, who has the smoke?
RPH, you're not shotcalling.
Do you know how to smoke that, like, fast?
Figure it out.
I don't know how to smoke.
I feel like we shouldn't go, like, actual A or B.
I'm blind.
We should go mid?
Wait, Nix, what did he say?
Yeah, mid seems like a good play.
Yeah, but I feel like we're not gonna be on this mid.
We're gonna be on a different map.
Well, another map seems like a good play.
It's true.
I'm doing that.
No, she's aimbotting.
I'm free res.
Oh my god.
There's like turrets here.
I'm free res.
Yeah?
You wanna say that again?
Oh yeah, what a useless fucking teammate.
Oh yeah, like the time you did in Res Miare?
It was the It was the end of the round.
It doesn't matter.
You didn't Res.
You got this your I believe in you.
The bullet went through them!
He healed, he healed, he healed.
The snipers are inconsistent!
Hey man, at least you look pretty.
Hey, at least now you know you won't play this character.
Everyone saw that, right?
That caster was on that bit.
At least we know you won't play this character.
Look straight up.
Solda Ero.
Oh, there you go, there you go!
You're gaming!
Granger, you're so fucked.
You're so fucked, bro.
Oh, the whiff!
Everyone's seen that shit, right?
That shit!
It's going through them!
Bro, you have another gun!
Why don't you get your other gun?
Cause I'm trying to see how this bullshit gun works, but half the time these bullets just more through these motherfuckers.
So bad.
Let's do a, uh, let's do something... nah, fucking whatever.
I give up.
I give up mid-talk, bro.
I'm over it.
How many more minutes till our next match?
Nine.
Nine minutes.
Yippee!
Solda Ero going out.
She's on the turret again!
It's a bot!
She'll always be on the turret!
I slowed her.
How is she so good at movement?
It's a fucking code.
The code's better than us.
No shit.
Oh, there's a guy right here.
Hello.
Yeah, I trusted you.
Oh.
Don't hold me, alright?
87.
Don't trust anyone, not even yourself.
My grenade's there next.
If you get hit by it, it's your fault.
I don't think you actually...
Guys, I'm getting shh.
Wait, we should experiment and see if nades hurt each other.
Like the frag grenades.
Alright, who wants to test mine?
Okay, I'll test it.
No, you can't hurt each other with those things.
With frag grenades?
I know you can flash each other.
Yeah, I don't think you can do team damage in any form.
Oh, okay, that's great.
Throwing himself.
I'm just gonna test it now.
Yeah, it needs to be tested.
Just to be sure.
I only listen to level 30s.
I'm level 5.
That's why we're not listening to you.
There's a goose low.
Your own nades do hurt you.
It does?
Yeah, but they don't hurt me.
Okay, wait, does it hurt?
I'm gonna throw my nade on you.
We just tried it.
I took 0 damage.
Oh, yeah.
No one ever trusts me, bro.
You're not level 30.
He's not level 30 either.
What are we doing about?
We're confirming for each other.
I threw the nade.
Yeah, yeah.
I got a donkey bull shooting at me.
A donkey bull shooting at you?
She is that, but I'm definitely...
I have a res 2...
Oh, wait, you have that?
Nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Dude, we got this easy.
Yeah, I mean, I bought this skin.
Now I'm cack girl.
Okay, so what...
Oh, I need to swap my util.
I keep forgetting that.
Okay, so what grenade do we need?
You need the wind storm and slow grenade, apparently.
Okay.
So healing grenade doesn't matter.
Interceptor nade is also good if you want like a club watson basically.
All right.
I'll do interceptor and wind grenade.
It's good if they want to throw smoke.
If they throw smokes on site, you just throw that shit and just delete all the smokes when they throw them.
Wait, do you have to do it before or after?
Before, before it's like watson gen.
Big boob.
All right.
Have you figured out what character you want to play now, Chirp4?
Playing the guy with DMR.
Because I think after this game, we have to...
We're going to the next match, right?
I play.
You want to play?
Let's play.
But see more anime.
You want to play?
Let's play.
Okay, no.
We're going to do it now.
Bro.
Oh my god.
They're mid.
I killed one.
You said do it more anime.
Yeah.
I did say that.
I won't practice my fucking D.
Yeah, I won't practice my D.
Yeah, one guy mid very low.
There you go.
Right here.
Guys, look at the ping on IPN.
What's IPN's ping?
160 words.
Dude, they're paper.
I can't hit them.
Oh shit.
Oh yeah, we also need to use paper more, guys.
Yeah, I am.
I'm not going to use less paper.
I'm going to use less paper.
I did not just watch you do that.
That was terrible.
I heard use more paper.
So I just listened to my ITL.
So you jumped into an 8.
Yeah, I listened to my ITL.
Use more paper.
The paper's into an 8.
Got it, guys.
You did not specify anything.
Do I have to tell you not to die?
Yes.
Just stay alive.
I didn't see the grenade.
Nobody said anything about the grenade.
I didn't see it.
Alright.
It's everyone's fault but yours.
Yep, I'm the main character.
I've been spotted.
It's A.
Guys, use your grenades.
Use your grenades.
Owwwwwwwww.
You got shot by...
AI.
I got shot by a 3 and M.
Bro.
I got to raise you here.
How did you die?
Oh, we're getting pushed.
What?
No.
These guys are way better at executing than we are.
Thank God.
They're not even talking to each other.
They actually like push as a team and shit.
Wait, did you just turn and go in?
What is that like?
These guys three men pushed at the same time.
That's crazy.
There's a lot we can learn from these bots, man.
Why don't we...
Why don't we work together as a team?
I don't understand.
I don't...
We all play as bots.
We play team games.
Overwatch is a team game.
Why don't we work together?
I blame you.
They three men swung my ass.
We should do that also, by the way.
That's the best way to win a fight.
To swing with as many numbers as possible.
I didn't set my turrets.
I forgot to.
I'm gonna do it next.
Don't die.
My turret is coming over.
Oh, yeah.
It is me.
Don't worry.
I have my...
He's dead.
I have my interceptor.
How far is...
Someone went mid.
It was not just me, but also mid.
She's flying.
Over here.
I pinged them.
I can't.
Are you f**king...
Use your n*****.
Why do you have a normal n*****?
But they're flying.
Woah.
Oh.
We won.
Yay.
Wow, we still have two more rounds.
Guys, we still have two more rounds, guys.
Wait, isn't our match starting?
After this game.
Yeah, the admins said they're gonna...
They're gonna come pick us up.
They know we're special in the head, so...
Yeah.
Who are we fighting against next game?
What are we fighting for?
Will they be easier or harder?
I can't believe...
I can't believe we even won our first round.
To be fair, I saw that in the tournament, some of the players are like top 100 Valorant players.
Guys.
So are we f**ked?
We have...
We have four ex-pro players in this team.
Don't even play Valorant.
I've played Valorant once.
What's... How many C's does Valorant have?
They're on A.
They're on A, guys.
They're f**ked up.
Are they already in?
I'm ulting.
We got one kill too.
On our end.
I'm heading over.
Whoa.
Be careful.
Is this RL?
I think I'm a fake.
I don't know where...
They're gonna come from.
On me.
Hope he knocks you.
This is my win.
Me next, Taemin.
Last is the sniper.
We can't lose to the sniper.
My win grenade killed me.
Sniper is useful.
I'm pushing the sniper.
I was stuck in a win grenade.
Go RPR.
You're doing it.
You guys are doing it.
What does this do?
What is that all?
She pulls you in and makes you die.
Oh.
Guys, one last game before we play a real game.
Oh no.
Why oh no?
Okay.
I don't think Nex believes in us guys.
I don't think he believes in us.
Honestly, can I even blame him at this point?
You literally made this team.
All I'm saying is I'm top damn in this bot match.
Yeah, I made this team, but you always did.
Oh my god.
Top damage in an AI match.
I think we know who's not the problem.
I feel like in FFVII, what charm does like being the deepest you want to guys?
I have max damage.
Yeah, I'm gold medals.
They're coming.
They are.
I threw my turret.
Enemy.
This is their kill joy up.
Bomb down.
Are you guys okay over there?
There's a kill joy up.
Everyone.
Oh hey, my turret is, Oh shit!
Okay, I did not see that guy.
Yeah!
I'm the best!
This is a good game.
We're not playing the same map already.
No, and each map is different.
Each match.
Because I found some nice places too.
You're so good at this bot.
Thank you.
Look at me, second to MVP.
Second to MVP.
Look at me guys.
Not the problem.
Oh wow, against the boss.
Look at the last place.
Donkey bird.
Problem.
Think about it this way.
Those bots have aimbot.
I'm better than aimbot.
You know what, surefer.
I'm gonna give you a like over here.
Thank you.
Hello.
Perfect time to call.
How is everyone doing?
Amazing.
We just won our game.
These guys don't depress.
That is nice.
Okay, so current situation.
The current game that is handling right now is going in a bit over time.
So we will...
They started hella late is what you're saying.
They did start hella late.
And then they're also really really close right now.
The game is really really close.
How did they do that?
How are they going so close?
I don't know.
Yeah, ours was so fast.
How come...
Well, that's because they started hella late.
They started about like...
8 minutes late.
So...
We should disqualify both teams.
Yeah, legit.
Wasn't there a penalty for like if they're late?
Look...
I remember that.
I read the rules.
Don't shoot the messenger, okay?
One of the teams...
One of the teams is called Skippity Rizzler.
I read the rules.
You guys were like...
We will...
We will penalize teams that are late.
I'm eating my food.
I can't do nothing about that.
Okay, the names are as it is.
Okay, but...
Listen, if you don't disqualify, we're gonna blame you.
Wait, I like how you censor yourself, but we're all like fucking swearing already.
So, yeah.
We all heard fuck.
So, like, it doesn't matter.
Because they have to censor it anyway.
I have a plug in that auto-censors my...
Oh!
No way.
That's...
So, if I just like regular talking, I go, fuck, shit.
Wait, what?
No way.
How do you do that?
So...
I'm just like...
That's insane.
That's crazy.
We gotta stay family friendly for the Twitch viewers, you know?
Wait, you can do that?
Yeah, you can do that?
We need that.
Lord knows I need that.
Don't get demonetized for swearing.
Yeah, no, no.
No demonetization here.
I need to get my AdSense.
It's okay.
We'll swear for you.
So, your editors will have to edit our censors for us.
Wait, I'm not allowed to swear?
No, you're allowed...
Be passionate, shorty.
You're allowed to swear if you want to.
We're not allowed to swear for you.
We're allowed to swear for you.
Okay, no, actually, don't say anything you ever want to say.
Don't say anything you want.
Actually, do not swear for me.
You need limiters.
Let me tell you.
You do not...
What do you mean I need limiters?
...say everything that you want.
Listen guys.
If I had that bleep function, my stream would literally be this.
It's just your fucking bloodlining.
It's okay.
We just send Morse code, you know?
Look, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, no!
I need a translator.
Alright, so I will get you guys ready for the next match.
The code should be ready.
Looks like...
You can't show it on stream, right?
I'm gonna go take a piss.
Okay, the game has just concluded.
Yay!
Dragged him over to our game now.
How do you leave a custom match?
You just have to leave on the bottom right.
Are we facing the winning team or the losing team?
You guys are facing the winning team.
Oh.
Fuck!
Let's go!
Guys, it's okay.
This is round robin day.
So like it doesn't matter.
Cause... right?
Wait, you're gonna be overconfident coming from a win and that's when we're gonna get him.
Yeah, this is the round robin... round robin day.
Okay.
If these guys started eight minutes late...
And it lasted...
And it lasted that long...
That means these guys are waiting until there's like 30 seconds left.
Oh yeah, true.
We can execute every round.
Oh, dude.
Waiters.
They're gonna be cringe.
So aggressiveness might be good against them cause they're not gonna expect like...
To get far.
Dumbasses to just run in.
Yeah, I gotta...
We gotta hide screen and don't show this part.
We're so...
We're dumb.
Free for yourself.
I'm smart.
If you're so smart, why are we losing?
It's not a bot.
It's this fucking...
It's this idiot.
If we show as the bot game show...
Wait, these are...
It's...
These guys play Valorant so much.
I'm gonna go pee, be right back.
Wait, we're playing against actual Valorant players.
Are you guys all joining?
Yeah, man.
Maybe.
Yeah.
All right.
No technical issues.
If I feel like it.
We're missing two people cause they went to the bathroom.
Okay.
So...
I'm gonna go pee.
Okay.
So, for you guys, you guys get to pick via coin flip, heads or tails.
The captain's not here.
The captain's always heads.
Heads.
But I choose heads.
You guys picked heads.
Give me one quick second.
You guys have lost, sadly.
No.
We lost again.
It's okay.
We're used to it.
Yeah.
We're used to it now.
Let me get the other team's pick and then I'll relay the information to you guys on defense or defense.
We're gonna get their attack.
All right?
Hey.
Guys.
They're gonna pick defense.
I don't...
I'm not...
I'm not as confident anymore.
At this point just have fun at the same time.
You guys sound like doomers right now.
Says you.
Like hello.
What do you mean says me?
I'm telling.
Your just tone of voice is always a doomer.
Hey.
That's just how the voice...
You guys are defending.
So make sure you guys are playing on Team B, alright?
Yeah, we're Team B!
Yay!
Let's go!
These guys are gonna attack us?
Yeah, these guys are gonna fuck us up!
Dude, it's over.
You're gonna get fucked in the ass real badly, okay?
Like, real fucking badly.
Even the admin doesn't believe in us!
Like, this is so fucked!
Woah, woah, woah!
They are just reaffirming what you're saying!
If we lose, it's your fault!
Even the admin doesn't believe in us!
I believe in you guys, okay?
Thank you, admin.
I don't trust you.
Guys, nades, nades, nades!
Oh, nades, nades, nades!
Who do I play?
Play this guy that goes boom with the DMR.
Oh, man...
What do you mean, oh, man?
I mean, play someone else there.
You wanna play?
Let's play!
Wait, did you find out how to TP?
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
This is a dust tomb, Matt.
This team is the most content defensive.
There's actually King's Row in this game.
Wait, there's King's Row?
All I'm saying... okay, listen.
All I'm saying, if this game mode for the tournament was escort, we would be winning by a mile, right, guys?
True.
They would actually be getting shit on.
No cap.
What map is this?
Oh, I remember this.
Yeah, I put...
Yeah, this is dust.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, legit dust.
Wait, we're on dust?
How do we... how do we...
Wait, everyone knows the callout's on dust?
Yeah, I know.
Wait!
Wait, I see it!
This is fucking long A!
Yeah, you've got this from up here.
From up here, sure, Vor.
Wait, I should...
So, we should hold mid.
Okay, I'll...
I guess slow down to complete.
I'll hold mid.
I'm scared.
I don't know how this map works, bro.
It's me.
It's dust, bro!
Use your nades!
They're top as well.
They can drop down on us.
On Highground.
Use your nades, not your aim!
Oh, I got flashed!
I'm blind!
Did I throw my nade?
I don't know if I threw it correctly.
Dude!
They walled?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got them flying up there!
One drop, two drop, two drop!
Oh, they're dropping.
What the fuck?
Oh, they got me!
Guys, they are very coordinated, too.
This guys are way too horny.
I got one!
Get one more!
There's four more!
That's why Shepard's got this.
Shepard's got this.
Watch this shit.
Oh ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho!
Don't die so you can see for next round!
Right below you!
Good maid.
I Stop believing I Held like dust you but the thing is there's a high girl.
Yeah, I didn't know they can draw from height Yeah, no high girls cheating Okay, he doesn't very very coordinated like they
Hey just fucking shoot them up complain sure for plays alone on a you guys stuck three
I'm the bot champion
They're going be they already found the weak site, you know what I mean
Might be a baby It might be a baby Checking I'm checking me.
It's Valorant, bro
Yeah, they're executing a they're Careful lurkers though Got my shit wasn't auto anymore.
This is really bad
Okay, I'm safe I got out Oh Oh, okay.
Yeah tougher for the roof top left from the roof Not going to play the one shot out there.
The first thing I've not gone over I'll talk to me one shot one channel
It's five it's fine.
It's fine Got them.
I got them got them nice one more
We got figured that's the bomb though.
Yeah.
She was obvious.
Among us.
It's us.
I'll go.
I'll look at mid.
Look at bottom mid.
We don't have hope for them.
We don't have hope for us.
Look at bottom mid.
What you looking at me for?
It's not B.
I see guy mid.
I see a guy mid.
Yeah, they're all top.
They're all high ground mid.
They're not bottom mid.
Top mid.
Yeah, yeah.
All of them.
They're gonna come...
Up mid.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're...
Oh, they're...
Oh, he fucking sees me on the paper Mario shit.
He's above me.
I think they're going A.
I don't know what he's coming for.
What the fuck is above you?
Mid, mid, mid.
Are they on B?
They're rotating B.
Rotating B.
They're rotating.
They're all rotating.
No, that angle is crazy.
That's a cheating angle.
They're chasing me down mid.
They're looking at me mid as well.
Oh god.
They're actually getting B.
Okay.
Hi.
They traded me.
He's already, my ass.
Oh, I quit.
We got one.
Guys...
Guys, we're getting a little better, right?
Guys?
Are we getting a little better?
You're supposed to move them.
I feel like this is Attax-sided, guys.
That's what you said the last game.
This one is definitely Attax-sided.
Guys, guys.
How about we push this?
Push them somewhere as a fight.
Let's push B.
Are we gonna push B?
Okay.
I can't push us if we're pushing.
They scanned them.
They usually scan.
Why would they scan if they're pushing?
Yeah, they're not gonna...
Pussy shit.
Some pussy shit.
I'm throwing one deep.
Oh, they scanned it.
See, I told you.
They're waiting for me.
They keep scanning.
They might rotate.
They might rotate because of...
Yeah, because they know that we're all there now.
Yeah, they're valid players, dude.
They have intel.
I don't see anybody, man.
What a sick nade.
They're still waiting for next.
Oh, next!
You can kill him.
I'm gonna ult and kill him.
Okay.
I got his ass.
I thirsted.
I ulted as well.
Someone just went short for, I think.
Yeah, they were shooting my side.
Yeah, they ulted.
I see a blue ult there.
He's KO'd.
Wait, someone's top.
One of them is invisible, guys.
I got spotted.
How the fuck do they know?
Ghost me.
Fucking putting up my turret.
On my side, surefour.
Behind you, sure.
They can't shoot through the turret.
I'm cheating.
Oh no.
It's not fair.
They have a full auto gun.
Okay, you scared the shit out of me.
No full auto in close quarters.
He's solo.
I headshot him.
Oh no.
No!
No full auto inside the building.
We are fucked.
I thought you said no doomers.
I'm not dooming anymore.
This is attack side, guys.
You wanna know why we are fucked?
Why?
Because I'm top fragging.
That's bad.
True.
I have M.
RBR has 297 damage?
Yeah, he hasn't done shit.
That's ping.
297 ping.
And you also only have 297 damage.
Your damage is roleplay to ping right now.
I'm doing 300 ping, bro.
Oh.
Hey, learn to swing.
Use your ping advantage.
Yeah, where's your ping advantage?
I'm a professional swinger.
They're going A.
I'm heading A.
A, A, A.
I got them flying.
I got the tornadoes on them.
Are you okay?
I got one.
Okay, I'm looking at mid.
I'm looking at mid with you.
They fell back.
Oh, next!
They are gonna rez.
Oh, they're all gonna rush me.
They're gonna rush me so bad.
No, I fucking knew it.
I got time so hard.
They're top mid.
They don't have wallhack.
Bullshit ass game.
I don't really have a gun.
When they rush me with an auto gun, it's Joe.
It's okay.
I'm watching sure for it.
Not frag out.
Oh my god.
He has the better fucking DMR.
I think this emote thing on my body has like...
Press tab!
Look at my ping!
I think he's like, hard carrying.
Fucking nerd.
It's not fair.
He plays with Shroud.
He knows how to do this.
There's no way!
No.
This game is so fucked.
Oh!
Attack is just easier.
Trust me, guys.
Oh my god.
There's a nade up there already.
What the fuck?
Trust me, guys.
I went to school.
Oh, bbbbb.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, don't be afraid to pull back.
Oh, I got exposed tracks on there.
Yeah, we're pulling back already.
Oh shit.
I'm gonna look at mid just in case.
They're pushing right side of the site.
Okay.
I can't like, I brain massaged!
I'm dead.
Res me.
Oh, I got wind granaded.
Oh, he's up here.
I'm coming for you over here.
I'm coming to your left.
I think they're gonna push.
I think they're feeling confident.
Yeah, I got knocked.
I got knocked.
One.
Two, they're behind.
Don't worry, I believe!
I believe!
Oh my god.
I never relied.
You got this.
No, watch the audio.
Audio, audio, audio.
That's an audio issue.
I still believe in us.
Guys, come on, man.
We gotta lock B down, man.
Bro, our B is not great.
Our B is not good.
None of our shit is good.
Wait, does that mean we're gonna fight the team that they won against?
Because that team almost won against them too.
So...
Can we not talk?
I feel like they placed us in the wrong bracket.
We should now be in this bracket.
Yeah, they thought too high of us.
There's like another bracket where there's no Valorant players.
There's osu!
players.
It's A!
Shiver's gonna die again!
Wow!
They did the most stupid fucking knife imaginable.
All I'm saying is that...
No, that is the first time I pushed that angle.
Wait, what is mid?
How did he come from mid?
Guys...
That KO knife is bullshit!
Nah, I'm telling you there seems to have been these guys...
You know I'm here because I peed.
Oh, he's looking at me.
Wait, are you guys okay?
Guys, I don't think you're okay.
Maybe I'll just save my gun.
Yeah, yeah.
Got my kill!
Yeah, now I'm top fragger!
Let's go!
Get shit on!
Pussy!
Who that shit on?
ZK?
Who the fuck is ZK?
I don't know.
You got shit on.
Congratulations, you got your first kill.
That was my second kill, dumbass.
But I didn't get the finish.
That was my second kill.
I didn't get the finish.
I'm playing on 300 ping!
You should be carrying me!
That's your choice!
No!
This server is fucked!
My rules!
I let the team go up in real time.
You recorded this.
You recruited this team!
I made a mistake.
Well, we're having fun.
Yeah, we're having so much fun.
It's mid.
They're mid as well.
They saw me.
I'm dead.
I've been spotted as well.
There's so many!
I'm just getting lagged.
I just lagged out completely.
I'm with you.
Oh, he's on the walls.
He's climbing walls.
Behind me!
Behind!
Bottom mid!
Bottom mid in our spawn!
Oh my god!
Wait, that guy shot by two angles?
What the fuck was that?
I just deleted so fast!
What the fuck?
He got res?
Yeah, that's it.
1v3.
1v2 is chasing.
Why is your server always in a situation where it's a 1v3?
I don't know.
Because I actually survive on my site.
Because he's playing B on Dust.
He's playing B on Dust.
Of course he's alone.
They built a wall!
They're trying to key me out!
You guys are getting 9-0.
They took your site without even using wall!
Nades, nades, guys.
Pick the right nades.
You guys are getting 9-0.
Whose fault is that?
The captain?
I was top fragger there.
Yeah, my bad for picking you guys.
Honestly, yeah.
You could have got any.
I could be preparing for my debut right now.
You guys...
You're preparing.
We're mentally preparing you right now.
Yeah, true.
You guys did good.
I give you a round of applause.
It's because our admin didn't believe in us.
So I went in with...
It's not over yet!
I went in with Doomer mentality.
Because my admin didn't believe in us.
You were Doomer from the start!
No, that's not true.
That was not true.
It's still winnable!
We could do overtime.
Can we get one point?
Let's get one point, guys.
I believe that you can win, okay?
I don't trust anything you say.
The comeback is real.
Right here.
Why can't we play against osu!
players?
Why can't we play against Valor players?
We can't play against osu!
players.
Did we?
Did we lose?
We lost against the current times team!
Yeah, do you need like a champion?
Yeah, but isn't a Valor player in that osu!
team?
Wait, this guy's just pushing me.
Don't shoot on!
Thirst him.
Just remember the thirst in.
I already did.
There's one bottom left of me.
I'm looking but I'm not seeing.
Oh, they're pushing me again.
Guys, you're all just sitting there!
They're pushing!
What did I just die to?
I got sniped!
Ethos you fucking nerd!
Oh I got flashed!
Goodbye!
This fucking nerd sniping in defense!
I mean, sure if I was sniping in defense...
Only on bot matches.
He was DMRing defense.
I'm looking at flanks right now.
Next has this, I'm watching you next.
I'm looking at flank right here.
Are we doing B?
Two in middle!
Okay I'm coming over.
Oh my god!
I don't know man.
One died.
It's like watching a bunch of chickens with their heads set up.
Shut the fuck up!
I can't play like that!
Use your Q!
I'm fucking using the panicking!
Kill her!
No!
That was close.
I'm flanking now because of you!
Kill her!
Now my character is sad because of you guys!
I got second fragger.
I got second.
You know what?
There's a pattern.
Surefour and I are always sharing like top and second.
I don't know.
Did anyone else break 2k?
Anyone else break 2k?
Didn't think so.
The fact that like...
The fact that I have 2000 damage when more than half the time they didn't even come to my site and I have to retake one before.
That's crazy.
I mean I didn't even break 1k!
I'm playing with 300.
I have to listen to your voice the entire time.
I have my utility out more than like my gun.
And I'm third.
How?
I have a grenade launcher that shoots slows more than I might.
Explain.
I was throwing nades the entire game!
So was IPN!
I was doing it right!
I understand.
Also I'm on 300 ping half of my damage doesn't register.
Oh now he's using ping as an excuse.
I said from the start I'm 300 ping.
Did you not hear me?
Last match I had 200.
That's playable.
300 is not playable.
Wait but you got...
Why did you get invited as a captain then knowing that you're gonna get 300 ping?
Oh wow that's still going.
I wasn't told that there's gonna be NA and JP only but...
Also I was told there's only gonna be new players in this tournament.
How do you straight up fucking lie to me?
Apex pro by the way.
Previously.
He's not helping us.
I'm just gonna go back to the game.
We got the third one for sure.
Yeah you know what?
Next is like our emotional support player right now.
He's here to...
I'm telling you.
Group A just isn't ours.
Group B however when we fight any of those guys...
It's due over.
Why are we in group A?
Why the fuck are we there?
If we win our last match can we still go through?
No this is round robin.
Second day we fight...
I'm not round robin.
One day this is like where we're figuring out our points.
So wait this doesn't matter?
This doesn't matter.
You guys are playing for seeding.
Yeah we're playing for seeding.
But then we're throwing on purpose.
We're throwing on purpose.
No cause if we...
Cause then people in the better seedings...
Wouldn't the people in the better seedings fight us?
Because they...
Yeah!
Why are you throwing on me?
We have to fight the B group!
We have to fight these guys again!
We gotta win one!
If we lock in the last round it's easy.
If we win at least one...
We get to fight somebody in group B.
Lock in!
Last match!
Last please.
I could be prepping my debut right now please.
You have 30 minutes I mean.
I mean yeah you could do it right now.
Yeah prep right now.
What do you mean I can't f***ing change my scenes right now?
Guys you should...
I'm not gonna debut on a Stranova tournament.
You should all watch Doki's debut because I voice acted in it.
Oh yeah he has voice lines in there.
I do.
Yeah no spoilers.
I'm a voice actor by the way.
Yeah.
Yeah he's not...
I don't think Nex cares.
I don't think he cares.
The voice line I'm not gonna spoil but it's a really good one.
How long is our next game?
Is this 30 minutes again?
You have another 30 minute break.
Your next game starts at 3pm PST.
Okay but like...
Are they playing right now or are they almost done?
They are...
They have yet to start this game.
They haven't even started!
It's because of guys.
What do you not understand?
They respected everybody.
They respect everybody.
I do have to say this.
I have to announce this.
So as you guys probably know, we actually have a substitute player.
So our practice didn't really matter.
You know?
This is not the reason we are 5 man lineup.
Yeah our member was supposed to be Roppelgator.
Way better than Nex.
That overwatch.
Way better.
Wait we could have done worse then.
How could we do worse?
How on earth could we do worse?
How did we get 4 rounds?
That one game.
That's because...
I don't know.
We weren't tainted and looming at that point.
We were just like... we cared more.
And now...
Now...
I'm a consistent player.
Me too.
I play the same whether I'm tilted, sad, happy or mad.
I'm happy even though we're losing.
I was still second fragger.
Similar to our first game.
I was second fragger.
No.
Yes I was.
I remember because I was happy about that.
It was like the one time.
That was the only time I was happy during that game.
What?
You're counting stats from the game when we lost 0-9?
No I'm counting stats from my first game.
And so you can't judge me for counting stats on the 0-9 when Surefour was fucking yelling about being top fragger there.
Yeah he was yelling.
But no one cared.
You guys don't care about him but you care about me.
That's fucked up.
MVP.
You weren't even MVP in the first one Surefour.
Team MVP bro.
Yeah I was team MVP bro.
I was MVP on the first and second.
I should go in coverage and start flaming him.
Oh shit.
I thought you actually went.
Yeah.
He put a black little square over our name.
Oh because of our name?
Oh yeah.
Yeah by the way guys.
So our team name is Overwatch 2.
But legally they couldn't do that.
But...
Yeah so we're watch over now.
So they had to put a...
I mean they could have done...
They could have told us not to use that name.
But then they committed to it.
And now they said legally they can't do that.
So...
So they have to like...
And I also want to point out that that was Doki's idea.
The illegal shit was Doki's idea.
Literally RPR was like hey can you give me a name.
You know RPR could have asked any other teammate for names.
Like he did not have to put my suggestion as a name.
I thought you were like intelligent or some shit.
My bad.
Anyway so yeah now our name is censored on the mainstream.
And you said you weren't doing pussy.
Yeah but then you could have been a pussy.
So I did it.
Yeah.
But then you could have been a pussy.
You should be careful with your words in the future I think.
Is that even me?
Don't use those words.
Because you know I will do it.
Guys I don't think I'm going to be invited to the next True Nova thing.
Guys I think I might be blacklisted.
What's a True Nova?
I mean...
It's True Nova.
Admin should make it sound like you won't.
You won't.
I mean...
No it's not.
There is a...
There is stuff that's happening that I'll say.
Um...
Listen now Admin we're not inviting you Doki.
Wait what's happening?
You don't get to hear.
Depending on your schedule I'd like to especially talk with you two.
RPR and Doki.
Fuck!
Why her?
What?
Am I in trouble?
No I wouldn't say you're in trouble.
Are we going to the principal's office?
No.
She made me do it.
He's literally the captain.
He should be responsible for the entire safety game.
She made me do it.
I will lick the M's.
That is the big thing though.
As the captain you gotta remember you're upholding the rest of your team.
No way.
That was your fault.
You should not have invited me.
No way.
Why am I...
Why is it just me?
Other people...
Surefer also was also in the...
What?
We were good.
We didn't do anything.
You're not the only one.
We're pulling approximately about 8 to 12 other people.
What did we do?
It's nothing you did.
It's just a separate project that is happening.
Oh we're getting sponsored!
No we're not.
No you're not.
We're playing a different project.
Let me put it in perspective.
We are broke as f**k for these projects.
Oh okay.
I gotta go somewhere later by the way.
So we're not in trouble.
We're not.
You are not in trouble.
You're in trouble Ducky.
I'm good.
RPR.
You represent the team.
You're in trouble!
I get sponsored!
Wait does that mean I can say whatever I want and RPR gets in trouble?
Yeah.
Yippee!
I transfer leadership to Ducky Bird.
No no no no.
I don't accept it.
I don't consent.
So wait if we get last place people will say RPR got last?
Yeah.
Okay let's lose guys.
It won't be me.
MVP.
SVP.
Yeah.
2k damage.
This just sounds tragic.
At least.
You know what's sad?
The captain not breaking 1k.
I'm gonna hang my mouse next game and let you do all the work.
That's pretty much what you did last game.
That's all I'm saying.
I hate this team bro!
I hate this team!
Why do I even invite you guys?
You chose this team!
You know what's crazy chat?
Never again!
I was first pick.
For the team.
That was the first person he asked.
To join this team.
Because you DM'd me.
Because you DM'd me and you were like...
You wanna play the chain game next to this.
By the way, you wanna join stream now?
Why did he immediately just turn him and that's on him?
I was literally first pick.
It's a knife or a knife type thing.
I made a mistake.
This is not a huge loss in judgment.
This is a fun tournament though, right?
Yeah, I'm having a lot of fun guys.
When we're actually in the game...
At least I'm gonna start late.
In judgment.
We're on time!
I'm punctual!
Yeah, we were all punctual.
Honestly, I thought Dok2 was gonna be late.
I'll make sure the seating tonight, you guys don't get absolute train railed tomorrow.
You can do that?
No, maybe...
If you want us to stay in this tournament longer...
You should make sure we...
We should make sure our opponents are here.
Yo, what is this?
A rigging the tournament?
Listen, Sherry.
You said you're broke, right?
You need the viewership.
Yeah, come on.
You want the viewership?
Listen, we might not be the best team, but we bring in the content.
You wanna keep us in this tournament as long as you can.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I better check on my bank account statement tomorrow and it just randomly shows plus 5k.
And then I'll be like...
Dok2!
Why me?
All I'm saying is that...
I have the highest viewership for Shranova right now.
And if you wanna...
I can't stay in this tournament longer.
I can't.
What is this?
This is blackmail, by the way.
This is blackmail, but we are not afraid to use it.
This is definitely blackmail.
But we are not afraid to use it.
We will blackmail Shranova.
It's not blackmail.
I'm saying...
If we somehow stay longer in the tournament...
Oh my god.
Tomorrow's YouTube clip is gonna be...
Team watch over blackmail Shranova.
I already see the title, man.
Hey guys.
Whatever happens...
I had a great time, guys.
We're not gonna cease in this test.
No, you're gonna get ceased in this test.
Because you let this happen as the team captain.
You're the captain.
Yeah, exactly.
You started the blackmail.
I'm just gonna disperse the cease and desist award, you guys.
I built on what you said.
You started the idea.
You planted the seed.
You see what you did, Shranova?
You saw what I did.
Now hold up.
Wait a minute.
Run that back.
You said I have responsibility.
Now they're stuck on this shit like it's true.
Because it is true.
And Admin said it.
Admin's word is law.
I'm not responsible for your actions.
And you know this.
I will not be.
Guys, how many more minutes do we have left?
Plenty.
Only 10 minutes passed since we argued.
We argued for only 10 minutes.
It's because we've done this.
Are you kidding me?
We've done this so many times already that we're kind of speedrunning now at this point.
We only argued for 10 minutes.
Guys, what can we talk about for 20 minutes?
I'm gonna fucking play a ranked game.
We can't because of the ranked dispersity.
No!
Why didn't you guys do your placements?
Let's just play Overwatch and Shranova.
We can wear holo-threes.
Wait, wait, wait.
Why didn't you guys do your placements?
You do placements too.
Wait, wait, Shiri.
Tomorrow, are we ever gonna play the Escort?
We do not have Escort planned in this tournament.
That's our strong game mode, by the way.
Because currently at this time and standing, Escort is very, very, very one-sided.
Yeah, it's heavily D-sided.
Yeah, well...
It's us-sided.
That's why they're not letting us play.
True.
Alright, guys.
Let's play Escort right now to pass the time.
To at least feel something.
Feel like one win.
Wait, is the custom game called RPR's Room?
Yeah, RPR's Room.
They went into your room, RPR, and 9-0'd you.
In your own house.
In my room, they fucked us.
That's so sad.
No, but that's because everyone left, so the title changed to RPR's Room.
No, we... oh yeah, that's true.
Yeah, the custom...
All of them left our room.
I think it's the same time.
An hour later, actually.
An hour later.
I'm gonna be so dead, man.
No way.
It's okay, we'll get Roflgator to the...
Okay, well...
Late arrivals will be penalized.
Where are the penalties?
I said that too!
Exploiting bugs or glitches will be prohibited.
What did you say next?
Rob hasn't even...
And also, each team has 10 minutes after the said time to get into the lobby.
After the said time to get into the lobby.
So since the game starts at 00 and 30 respectively, So since the game starts at 00 and 30 respectively, you have up until 10 and 40 respectively.
Alright guys, see you in 30 minutes.
I have time.
Where are you going?
It's like the principal doesn't show up in 10 minutes.
You can leave.
You wanna start 10 minutes late and start at 310 and then delay Doki's...
Yeah, I'm leaving exactly at 330.
Oh my!
I'm just gonna leave the match.
Suddenly I fell over in my room.
And passed out.
For half an hour.
That means I have the power.
The power to hold us hostage?
I will leave regardless if you're holding us hostage.
I'll have you know, if someone wastes my time in League, I will hostage them.
If they feed their lane, I will hostage them.
Alright guys, come on.
Let's just play one escort guys.
Just anything.
Please.
Fine.
Yay!
I'm ready.
IP in.
I'm launching Among Us.
Who are you gonna play Among Us with?
What the fuck?
Himself.
He's his worst enemy.
He's got two personalities.
He's fucking it.
It's like playing Smolity Box Among Us.
Oh my gosh, just like...
One of you is a beast.
Alright, let's do this guys.
Let's win one game in our lives.
Surely we'll win.
Surely.
Guys, I believe in us.
There's no way.
Alright guys.
Guys, this is gonna be the day we win a game.
...
No.
Yeah.
I need a map.
We're gonna win this game.
Believe in us.
We can't be...
This is Overwatch now.
Yeah, this is Overwatch.
We're Overwatch players.
Hey guys, we're against all bots.
Except for Ori and Nyx and Novarine.
There's no men in this game.
Wait, those are all bots, aren't they?
No, only two of them are not.
Two of them are real people, right?
What if they are?
What?
Let me ask them.
Are you real?
Yeah, type in team chat.
Or like game chat.
Oh hey, we're D-sided.
That means we're gonna win.
We're gonna win.
Yippee!
Yay!
I think there are...
There's no real people anymore.
It's King's Row!
No, it's not.
Yes, it is!
It is.
It's legally distinct King's Row, guys.
It's not King's Row.
It's Queen's Row!
Let's go!
Did you just die to a bot?
Yeah, they are aimbotting.
Do not peek them.
Wait, I can control my bear.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like a solvador.
That's what they did to us, remember?
Yeah.
And then we literally just looked at them.
That guy is in the air, 1 HP.
Wait, that's broken.
He's gonna turret.
Oh, he turrets, he turrets.
Woo!
It's okay, I didn't die to a bot yet.
One is on the payload.
Oh, he's doing that dumb cringe shit.
Yeah, so does.
I hate that shit.
I wish Overwatch has it.
Only Overwatch has that.
She hates that shit.
I need healing!
Mercy!
We don't have mercy.
He has gotta live.
Anyone got a pocket mercy or what?
God, no.
We just want a frag now.
What is that?
We have grenades.
We have heal grenades.
Just use that.
Come to my heal grenade.
I don't have heal grenades.
Yeah, I picked it up.
They are shooting teddy bear.
No, not the teddy bear.
I'm just saying.
These bots ain't shit.
Cause they are bots.
They are level 1 bots.
What do you mean?
Except next die to one of them.
No.
Yeah, I saw you dying.
It was a team kill.
I just saw you die.
They are not smacked off for what?
You are in spawn.
You guys died to them too.
I jumped off the map.
They are going to cap the first point.
They are not.
I'm here.
I'm active.
Oh, what a nade.
That was a huge nade.
I'm going to throw a nade too.
I can't see.
There is a guy right up top.
I'm flashing him.
Watch out, Donkey.
No.
I didn't think you were flashing now.
Sorry.
Oh, shit.
I avenged you.
I blame the guy that flashed me.
Two more seconds.
I'm back in it.
Damn, next.
What?
Guys, we should have been playing this mode instead.
True.
To think.
RPR invited Apex and Overwatch players for a Valorant portion.
How was I supposed to know which game mode it was going to be?
Because it was...
It's like the rules.
What do you mean?
I can tell now you didn't.
You didn't read the meter.
I did.
I knew it was going to be the Valorant.
I knew it was going to be the Valorant part.
You're a nerd.
Only nerds read.
Yeah.
And nerds are winning.
The nerds are winning.
Wait, they're using nades.
They're real people.
Ow, ow, ow.
Wait, some of them are actually...
Oh, the bots can use nades?
Oh, okay.
They're the goats.
Yeah, they're aimbotters.
Alright.
We're doing it, guys.
They're going to cap.
We're not doing shit.
C9.
Even in this game, we C9.
Surefire, are you okay?
Does it bring PTSD?
I was dead.
Nothing I can do about it.
We're going to lose the bots.
No, we're not.
We're delaying this because we have fucking 10 more minutes.
Dude, look at me.
Look at where...
I'm moment king.
It's okay, guys.
On the point!
She's aiming at me.
I mean, they're literally robots.
So, I'm going to fucking throw my turret.
Fuck this.
I don't care.
They're beating.
Yay!
I'm getting cooked!
More tornadoes!
What's that shit in the sky?
He's just beaming in...
Did you nade flash me?
Did you fucking...
We're just spawn camping bots.
On you.
Oh, nice.
He's dead.
I'm so sure I'm going to die an embarrassing death.
Nice.
Next, I got you.
Fly high, bird.
I need some healing.
Oh!
Oh my god, the amount of headshots I just delivered.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
I'm the only one!
Oh, there's an 8.
Ow.
Fuck.
That's so funny.
Yay!
I'm in here.
Paper Marioing.
Up here, you're literally like in there.
You're welcome.
I saved your life.
That's what teammates do to each other.
Not... not you.
The fuck?
What are they?
I'm killing them in spawn.
What do you mean, where are they?
Where are they?
How do they see 9-us?
Shoot that guy!
I shot him.
I got ace.
This should have been...
This should have been our game.
This should have been our game mode.
They're pushing C payload!
How the fuck is she pushing the payload?
They're just going paper mode and like staying on it.
Yeah, they're just on paper mode and like fuck with us.
That's fucked up that they programmed that into the bot.
That's actually messed up.
That should not be a bot.
I'm a real player.
That should not be a program.
Now I'm pretty sure the bots are like AI based on like other players.
That's so messed up.
How did they spawn by the way?
What?
Like they learn from players.
They learn how to cheese from other players.
That's funny as fuck actually.
That's really good AI learning.
Does that mean that...
That's why they can see the payload.
They were learning from me.
Guys, I think they're pushing again.
Oh, it's C9 again.
Oh my fucking god.
How the fuck did we keep getting behind?
How do they do this?
I'm gonna put turrets on the guy.
I'm dead.
The AI just like no-clipped in there.
Yeah, they saw that.
They just teleport into the car.
I mean, Nadia, what the fuck?
Yeah, that guy is definitely AI.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
There's no way that guy was real.
He wants to flank again.
Peer!
That was scary.
Wow!
Goodbye.
Nice.
Yeah, I'm killing bots.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
I have 200 ping now.
Wait, you're right.
This is actually a better server for you.
I told you.
I'm getting griefed.
They're griefing me on purpose.
Just request a server.
It's only one server.
San Francisco...
Wait, is it actually only one server?
Yeah, it is.
Okay, that's pretty funny.
They're in the tunnel!
Oh!
They should give us the Asia servers.
Japan?
Yeah.
That's way better for me.
350?
Yeah.
I mean, it would equalize everybody else.
Yeah, I would be using it though.
Guys, C9.
C9.
C9, guys.
I got him.
Because we were getting C9 again, guys.
Yeah!
Wow.
Seven more minutes and we get to play.
Seven more...
Okay.
I mean, we won't too fast.
Like, we're just too good.
Okay, good IPN stole 11p, bro.
I healed more than you, though.
I healed the most.
How did I heal?
Apparently, they just started the game.
What?
No way, right?
Someone said they're just starting out.
Someone opened the stream right now and checked.
Someone...
I opened my own stream, my bad.
It's 2-7.
Whoever said that in your chat, they're lying.
I got one guy.
Liar!
Yeah, my chat was lying.
My one guy.
Fucking liar.
Wait, are we playing the team that's winning or the team that's losing?
I don't know.
Knowing us, we're gonna play against the winners.
How's the turning going?
We're steamrolling.
Yeah.
In certain modes.
Yeah, against bots, there's no chance.
We literally cannot lose a round.
Technically, we broke our last streak.
Yeah, we went 9-0 last game.
No, no, we won last game.
Remember?
We won.
Yeah, I said we went 9-0.
Alright, guys.
We're just waiting.
We're waiting at 7 more minutes to...
Till our next game.
Where we hopefully don't get 9-0'd.
It's 2-8.
Oh, it's almost time.
They shouldn't have a break.
They should go straight into playing against us.
I put the Among Us lobby code in the lobby.
Alright, what?
Alright, should I put it for... Do you want to play against us?
Should we play against our viewers too?
Yeah.
Hey, viewers.
If you want to join Surefour, it's Among Us lobby.
It was green!
Green!
DC, I'm on ramp!
If you guys want to join...
Surefour will have people to play with.
Yeah, yeah.
He needs people to play with, guys.
Someone, please.
He's not even streaming.
He's literally doing this because he likes Among Us.
He's not even streaming, guys.
Do you actually like Among Us?
No.
Wait, you don't?
But you said you used to play Among Us a lot.
No, I stopped playing.
Because everyone would always first time kill me because I'm too strong and powerful at Among Us.
Yeah, that's why.
Yeah, I remember that too.
I was also one of the Harbingers.
So don't kill him first.
That's one of the four horsemen of the apocalypse.
What does that even mean?
He was one of the first people that started the Among Us.
Bad.
Yeah.
He was there.
Look what you did, you fucking asshole.
Among Us ruined gaming.
It ruined everything.
It ruined people.
And trusting to people.
You can't trust nobody no more.
Among Us invented the term gaslighting.
No, it invented the term sus.
Sus?
Hello.
Are we allowed to play now?
I am getting your lobby codes.
Yeah.
We are on schedule.
We are actually early now.
Yeah.
Wow.
Don't worry.
I am going to post your Among Us code in your chat as well, Surefour.
So they know.
We are playing against Skibidy Rizzlers.
Okay.
We can't lose.
We lose against Skibidy Rizzlers.
Are they good?
The last game that has happened, the score was 9-2.
But which team were they fighting against?
Our first team.
They were fighting against your first team.
Oh, okay.
So we are two points better than them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got it.
We can win.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this.
Guys, we are two points better than them.
Bring them to Queens Row.
I will show them.
Queens Row.
For the sake of this, this is not on me.
This was pinged to me by some of your community members.
Out of the blue.
Tell Doki to throw the game.
You have a debut to prepare for.
Okay.
But we can just win fast.
We can literally just win.
Tell the enemy team to throw the game for me.
Because today is my celebration day.
Yeah.
I have to be happy.
Look at the levels.
5, 13, 9, 9, 11.
We are better on levels than them.
Can you rename the bots in this game?
Just kick RPR.
Put in a maximum AI bot.
Rename it.
I don't know.
That would be such an improvement.
Dude, you guys are laughing.
Play on 300 ping then.
This is your choice.
Someone beat us right now.
Give her 300 ping.
This is literally your choice.
My life.
My rules.
I hate it here.
I hate this game.
No, I love this game.
I hate you guys.
But yes.
I personally love this game.
This is all recorded for the But yes.
I corrected myself because I actually do like this game, but you guys make it terrible for me.
RPR heads or tails?
Tails.
He says...
Wait, you gotta write it.
You don't even know what side we're on.
RPR English or Spanish?
Eh?
Do you not know the meme?
Come on.
Oh, he doesn't know the meme!
I know, it's English or Spanish.
I don't play by your rules.
Just say English or Spanish!
I should've won tails!
Wait, what did we get?
Are you doing defense or attack?
We lost.
We've lost every coin flip.
No, we won the first one.
But we were always defensing.
Because I chose defense.
Oh.
You don't even know which side is defense or attack.
Attack side.
Ain't no way.
There ain't no way in us.
Oh my god, we're gonna lose again.
Defense side is B.
Why there ain't no way in us?
What did we do?
Among us.
I can't believe Surefour didn't actually start his Among Us lobby.
Wait, did you not?
No, it was B!
We were gonna give you people to play with, Surefour.
That's fucked up.
Wait, can I?
You can't trust the VTuber fans.
No!
Cool.
They'll join my Among Us lobby and dox me.
Oh shit!
Sussy.
Ugh.
What are we waiting for?
Are they still deciding attack or defense?
They just said ain't no way and then nothing else.
I thought that was one of the admins.
Why didn't he wanna swap?
I guess we swap.
Oh, we swap, yeah.
Am I swapping?
I'll go here.
Alright.
I swap.
They want defense.
They made a grave mistake.
But we always suck at attack.
We've done the worst.
Joke's over.
Your day.
Welcome to my world.
Have we all figured out what we wanna sure for already after calling you out?
Sure for already after calling you out?
Watch this!
Watch this is crazy.
Yeah, we're entering the game!
Alright, which map is this?
Wait, that's us!
What's this?
Valerie map?
We are playing a wallhack, bitch.
What does Sova say when they ult?
I don't fucking know.
Can I play the healer now?
Because we're attacking instead of the goo lady?
You can play whatever you want, man.
You know what you're doing.
Oh, I almost forgot to...
Nades, nades, nades!
I'm gonna run flash.
Flash bang!
In Windstorm.
Guys...
Do you think we can win, guys?
I do.
Alright.
You guys play like bitches!
Okay, sure, but why don't you be IGL?
Why don't you be IGL?
I can't.
What is this?
Why can't you?
Because if I AGL, the demon comes out.
I know this map!
This is the Valerie map!
That's what I'm saying!
Look, they even have the flowerpots!
They have the flowerpot in the middle!
The admin instantly leaves as soon as we start talking about Valerie.
Wait, which side are we going?
I'm not the IGL, but I think B is nice.
I can easily push this with my wallhack.
I'm with next then.
I'm with him.
Oh my god, her boob is in 2D mode.
I can kill you as well.
I'm goody.
I'm next to you.
Oh, there's people here, yeah.
I got one on onehack.
One on onehack.
Swing last!
Dude, your wind fucked me.
He's pushing up.
Oh, surefour.
He's one though.
Be on your way.
There's two of them!
I got one.
It's a 2v2.
Can I get surefour up?
How much time you got?
I don't know.
One more up there.
Rescuing, rescuing.
You see him?
Oh, that's a lot.
He's right here, guys.
Revive me, revive me.
He's throwing bomba.
Come to me, Ipeen, come to me.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, flashbang.
I'm blind, I'm blind!
It's one guy.
It's literally one guy.
Don't get one guy.
Don't get one guy, please.
I see him, I see him.
Smoking.
I'm gonna plant the bomb.
Watch me.
He's on the roof!
Are you still planning after that?
Don't surefour.
On the right side.
I'm gonna slow him.
That was a good shot.
360.
Buy armor, buy armor.
I'm gonna get heavy armor.
Come on.
I'm not living long enough for regen, guys.
Number one, Vecrolai.
Who are we pushing?
I just do the same thing.
I got pictures.
I'm fully supported.
Guys, rule of thumb is do until it don't work.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna queue this door.
Because that's how he got us last time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Someone hold that and then see.
Do until no more work.
One to the right side.
I'm looking for us.
I built a wall.
He painted it.
I'm looking at flank right now.
They're gone.
We wanna go right?
Or no?
I got B long.
I'm pushing.
I'm looking at our flanks, guys.
I'm smoking this.
That's my wall.
That's our wall.
I'm gonna hold this.
I'm holding this.
I'm gonna plant.
You plant the bomb.
I'm gonna flash deep.
I'm gonna spot it.
I'm flashing.
I'm gonna throw a nade.
I'm watching top lane.
I threw a nade over there.
I'm so good.
We got the bomb.
I'm covering for you next.
They're not here, I think.
I got one.
One next to me.
One of you just in case.
Close left.
Two of them.
He's dead.
On me.
Oh shit.
I got another one.
We're playing Valorant, guys.
We're actually playing Valorant.
Keep going until no longer work.
We're looking at corners.
And playing slow.
Keep doing until no longer work.
Let's push A.
What the fuck?
Keep doing until no longer work.
Push A.
We gotta follow Sheriff because he's gonna push A.
I'm pushing A.
We're gonna lose this round.
We're playing Stranova, guys.
We're playing Stranova.
I'm just embossing you.
I'm gonna be insane.
I don't know how they show up.
I've never played this map before.
I'm making wall.
Pushing with the wall.
I'm smoking.
I'm going invisibility mode.
I plant bomb.
Please hold me.
Bomb planting.
It was bad.
The bear is coming over here.
I'm playing invisible on site.
The bear...
He's nading.
He's one.
Get his ass.
He naded.
Next.
Jett revive me.
Three guys here.
Three dudes.
Help me.
Behind you.
He's one.
I got flash.
I'm not the best.
I got another.
Play bomb.
One HP.
One HP on one guy.
Oh.
Yeah.
We got bomb.
I think.
Yeah.
Double kill.
We played Tranova guys.
We're doing it.
We're doing Tranova.
Now we're running back B.
Running back B.
Running it back.
Wait.
Next.
Yeah.
Someone.
You can just literally double kill him.
I'm gonna ult you.
Hard double kill.
What does your thingy do?
I give you fucking...
Oh my god.
I am always right.
Shurper did the right call.
Just tell me if you're pushing.
Oh I'm going.
I'm going.
I messed up the...
I'm looking at the...
It didn't work.
He's dead.
Help me.
I res'd.
Help him.
There's more.
Help.
Help me.
Help me now.
Me next.
Plant the bomb.
Oh my god.
There's like ice bears and big bears.
Okay.
I got one but they're res'ing.
Plant the bomb.
They got the res off.
Now he's coming over to finish the job.
One more.
Two more.
Okay this is a 2v3.
Oh that was a good nade.
Fuck he's low.
They're both here on me.
On me.
On my...
It's okay.
It's a 2v...
It's a 1v... Oh it's a 1v3.
It's not okay anymore.
It's okay.
I'm clutch master.
You have 5 HP.
5 HP.
Oh he has 106.
The armor's fucking...
God.
Where the fuck killing me?
Okay.
Okay next.
You become strong but not warm enough.
Where the fuck did they shoot me from?
But not warm you free strong.
I wasn't sure.
You know.
Was he standing on that fucking box?
What?
What happened?
He said you're clutch master.
Back away.
Sometime.
Sometime you winning.
Sometime you losing.
Yeah yeah we go A.
We go A?
Oh okay.
You only do until it all work.
And then when no work we go other stuff.
But last time A worked.
But B didn't work that game.
Guys we got it.
Guys we can't just suddenly stop being teamwork.
Okay guys?
Guys teamwork.
Alright.
Oh.
One clip.
Alright.
Self-presure.
Nooo.
I double push.
One shot.
Sniper.
I flashbang.
I have no smoke.
I'm.
Why am I flying?
Oh what the fuck.
Okay.
Did we have.
Let's split the bomb guys.
Who has the bomb?
Me me.
But I can't.
They're everywhere.
I'm holding.
Yeah hold me then.
Okay I got one.
Oh there's another.
I got my one.
Nice bomb.
I'm here in the water.
Guys.
I'm so safe.
I'm blind.
Get fucked.
I'm so safe.
Trust me.
Yeah okay.
I'm gonna die for you.
Okay.
Oh no it's a turret.
Oh no.
I got this.
Did you actually got this?
2v3 situation.
I kill you next.
I kill you.
Yeah.
Got him.
Wait our peer has 200 ping this time.
He actually has good ping.
Does anyone else wants to plant the bomb?
No.
We're going B.
No it's okay.
You can go plant it.
I did it.
You're the support.
Support always plant bombs.
Go B.
More B long.
We succeeded A.
What if we all stand like this and push.
I'm down.
Alright.
There's no way they'll see us.
Right?
Yeah.
There's no way.
We're just a bunch of enemy girls.
Hold on.
Okay now they'll see us.
B long clear.
Okay we're fucking around.
We're fucking around right now.
Even though I don't have a lot of time.
They're not really coming.
They're pushing all the way B long.
They're not coming.
I feel like we should help.
Go A.
Okay.
There's a bear.
I'm getting boomed.
They know.
Okay.
Just flip it around guys.
They're coming.
Oh no.
Guys we're not pushing.
No.
We're pushing with...
Oh you're dead.
Guys why are we saying a middle map no reason?
Okay here we go.
We go.
That was my nade.
Sorry I didn't know we were gonna go there.
I didn't know we were gonna go there.
They're watching mid and mid end.
Oh you're so good.
Guys.
Kill donkey.
I need reload too.
Two more.
Wait.
I'm building a wall.
Just move.
Okay.
I'm gonna go the other side.
Guys get the bomba next.
Get the bomba.
Where's the bomba?
Someone got the bomba.
Kill the...
Solo.
On site.
Careful on site.
The ice girl.
Where's the ice girl?
Oh my god.
The reload.
No.
Why are you deagling?
That's how to reload the other gun.
Buy the other pistol.
The one... Okay guys.
My... We go B side.
You guys no AFK in mid.
I wall.
Yeah.
You guys stop fucking around guys.
It's 4-2.
They can turn this around.
No.
I wall.
You fucking around.
My wall is opaque.
I'm ready.
Wait.
Someone is AFK.
Oh okay.
I was like who's that AFK?
Okay.
I'm queuing this right side.
I take bomba.
I don't know why.
I'm queuing right side now.
Big mistake maybe.
Okay.
This is clear.
Oh shit.
Oh I've been spotted.
I've been spotted by Fushia.
Okay.
They know about our...
I'm going the right.
I'm looking at right side.
Wait.
I'm coming.
I cut off.
I'm getting rid of the bear.
I got rid of the bear.
They're trying to push.
That guy got smoked.
He got smoked.
I'm gonna... Oh shit.
There's a guy.
I'm looking.
Wait.
I'm getting shot from behind.
Where am I getting shot from?
Flat bomb.
He's bomb himself.
She's up.
Oh shit.
I was looking at the other guy.
She gets self -revive.
It's her self-revive.
No I'm flying.
Fushia has a self-revive.
You have to double tap her.
Is that a passive or is it like...
I got two guys above me coming from behind.
One guy in front of me coming from the front.
It's not her ult?
Oh wait.
I think it is a passive.
I'm not sure.
Two guys in front of me.
Fuck I'm dead.
They're defusing.
Oh.
Did they... Oh they defused.
Guys we need to stop.
We need to stop fucking running guys.
Guys we need to stop this.
This is a defense map you know.
Stop this three middle bullshit.
Go three B two middle.
I'm helping.
Four B long.
Okay.
B is free.
I'm going to RPR.
One of our biggest problems as a team is some of you just jerk off in mid lane for no reason.
What I'm covering.
Wait.
Mid lane bad?
Who are you covering?
Bomb site?
We on tech.
You just think you always deal in mid.
Just like bait them you know.
Oh okay.
I'll bait them.
Yeah.
Throw a grenade.
I can literally cut off the entire half of the B site.
Yeah we plant for free.
Plant for free.
Then we play tight.
Smart.
Doesn't matter.
Go up.
We're behind.
Oh my god.
All three are mid.
All three mid.
I'm planting.
I had to cover two angles.
There's a guy here.
Guy in pink.
No.
No I fucked up.
Behind.
Where we came from?
They were all spreading mid.
Help.
No.
I got one.
I'm Qing you.
Oh no.
How did you hit that you cheater?
You cheater.
I'm Qing you.
Bruh.
I think we need a new strat.
I don't think we should go B and E.
No no no.
So once we get the bomb though.
We just have to play defensively.
Once they're all around the bomb.
We literally just.
You know.
I'm just saying.
B long was free.
Switching.
Okay now I'm playing this lady.
Shit.
Guys this is very good.
I'm throwing.
Guys guys guys.
Believe in the vision guys.
Right here.
Oh she's playing.
Oh wait.
Sure you can rez people with your abilities.
Yeah but I have sniper rifle.
Believe in the vision guys.
I'm playing a male character.
Believe in the vision.
Oh no.
He has a dick.
Wait I thought we were trying.
What happened?
Don't worry this guy is goaded.
I thought we were trying.
Yeah we are trying.
This is.
I'm doing this for us.
Chad which is better this one or this one?
I'm going to go B.
I've never played this map so I don't know where to put my turrets.
We just attacked.
You know where we come from.
Yeah but.
Not really.
I don't remember.
I guess I could.
It's right here.
Probably.
I'm trying to figure out where they come from.
I got professionals in chat.
I am holding.
I am holding midel.
Someone needs to hold A.
Yeah someone needs to hold A.
I'm trying to figure out where to put turrets.
I'm close quarter combat only.
I guess I could put a turret on the site.
Pushing me hard.
I don't see A.
I'm going behind him.
Guys I forgot to get the nades.
I was so confused.
I'm a VTuber right now.
What behind?
I'm blind.
They smoked us.
I'm going to drop to the ground.
They are top left mid.
Top left mid.
On me.
Can I heal myself?
I'm fucked.
They are so deep into A.
I'm heading over.
Planted the bomb.
I don't know where they are.
They are all...
Can you speak?
I am...
I'm going to come over.
I got my two.
Did you thirst?
I thirsted one.
Oh no.
I thirsted one of your kills.
It's a 3v2.
I got one as well.
Oh my god.
He is going to rest over here.
Yeah but the bomb though.
Yeah.
He has this.
I don't know where they are.
He is leaving.
Goodbye.
I saw that.
I'm like goodbye.
It's okay guys.
We got this.
I need to know where to put my turrets.
Let's see.
You will not kill my allies.
Guys I cannot play A or B.
I can only play mid.
I'm putting turrets on the site.
And I will put it over here.
I go B I guess.
I'm B.
Right now.
We can play off the B side.
We don't have to be on the B side.
As long as we have mid we can retake B.
I'm trying to figure out how to defend.
They are fucking smoking me in mid.
They are wall hacking me.
And they are cheating.
It's not B.
It's A.
They are going mid.
I'm going.
I'm rotating.
They are rotating back to B.
Mid.
They are coming mid.
We got a crossfire.
No we don't.
I'm smoked.
They rushed me too.
I'm looking from here.
There are two over there.
They used an ability on me.
I'm slowed.
I might need help.
Who the fuck is your cops coming?
My bad.
Guys they are calling an ambulance.
But not for me.
I'm pushing up.
I can look from the flank here.
I got one.
Nice.
I got him.
I got trade.
Here.
That's the last guy.
I'm gonna try and get Doki up.
Yeah he's pushing me away.
Fucking stop.
Leave me alone.
That guy was pushing me back.
He's killing me.
I can hit him later.
I got you in this corner.
He's alone.
Just push him.
It's only him.
He's one height up.
Go.
He's in the corner.
I'm going.
He's nearly won.
Come on.
There.
Sniper rifle.
I have sniper rifle.
Wait.
What nade did you have?
I didn't have any nades.
I used them.
Oh.
Okay.
Guys this is way too close.
Hey.
Start stealing.
Listen to me.
Actually just leave B site.
Don't even play up there.
Play three in mid.
And then if they take B we can retake.
It's so easy to retake this stupid site.
I'm putting turrets up for us.
Just in case.
Play mid towards A.
I feel like A is way harder to retake.
I'm gonna play on the side behind here.
So if you run here next I can back you up.
They're coming by Fushia.
They're coming in the left mid.
Whatever the fuck that is.
I don't even know if I'm in a good spot when it comes to...
I'm blind!
They're not mid yet.
I'm looking.
I'm looking too.
I have wallhack in five.
AA.
There's one on A site somehow.
Heading over.
I see two on A.
Okay.
No one mid.
It's clear.
I'm heading over.
I need helping.
I'm here.
That guy was one.
Oh there's a guy to my left here.
I know I'm trying to...
He's 97.
Cracked him.
Guy planting is cracked.
I cracked another guy.
There's one.
One dead.
I don't know where the others are.
He's down there in front of me.
I don't know how to ping him.
He's right in front of me.
One HP right here.
Got him.
Nice.
Defended.
We're doing it.
Don't get overconfident though.
Please.
Overconfident is a slow but insidious killer.
Every time we get overconfident we fuck out.
Just play like we did.
I'm heading over to...
that mob turrets.
I'm just gonna put it here.
I have...
I have my ult for retake.
If we need to use it.
I have...
Heroes never die.
Wait so you're on Mercy.
Surefire is on Mercy player.
No.
No one is being my kitten.
They're also... they're over here too.
Look at this next.
Wait.
Behind.
Oh fuck.
Next one.
They're right here.
On your right.
Up here.
Fuck.
Maybe I should have went forward instead of backwards.
They're all heading down.
It's B guys.
B.
Oh.
They ulted B.
I'm putting my turret down but I don't know if it's working.
I can't see.
Next is crazy.
On me.
They ulted.
They ulted on my side.
They ulted my side.
Oh I got him.
Yes Doki.
Yes.
No.
They see.
One more on Doki's body.
They're resing.
They might res.
I got one.
Above you guys.
Nice job above you guys.
On the left.
Inside.
He's on site.
He's low.
One more.
There's more.
There's a lot.
There.
One B2.
He's inside.
Low.
We have to defuse though.
Here.
Behind you.
Nice.
Defuse.
Bomba.
We have time?
I have hesitation.
Hey pick me up.
I need helping.
Help me.
Where are we at?
You watched him die.
Okay.
I got Phoenix ult.
I... I think with this...
What I do is I Phoenix ult right here.
Next.
And I run it down mid like a f**king idiot.
Okay.
I will install like Volhec and tell you where they are.
I want to suck your blood.
Where did that come from?
He's gonna like kill Dracula for a second.
I'm ulti.
Yeah.
There's only one to the left.
They're pushing like mega ult.
There's another one.
Yeah.
There's two.
There's four of them.
We're good.
Dex, you should not be sacrificing your life.
You do not have Phoenix ult.
Yeah.
I Phoenix ulted.
Wait.
There's someone on me.
There's someone on my Alita.
Help.
They pushed the far side.
I'm with you.
That is true.
He's not lying.
They're body shot.
They're one.
Got him.
I'm gonna stay here.
I'm anchoring B.
Just in case.
We left mid.
So she's dead on B in three seconds.
No, I'm not.
I'm still alive.
I can heal you next.
Where are you?
There's nobody in B.
There's nobody in B yet.
My turrets are...
They got top mid.
Leave it if you have to.
I got the opportune spot.
There's a sniper.
There's a sniper on the B.
Let them go.
Let them come in.
They're all coming to me.
Okay.
Pull back.
Play DV.
Defense.
They're coming up.
Two guys top right.
Fuck is this guy shooting at?
Wall hacker.
Are they rotating?
Are they staying there?
Yeah.
My turret.
They're here.
They're breaking turrets right now.
They are wall hacking me.
I hit one for 159.
I'm pushing the B.
I'm slowed.
They're pushing us here.
They went high ground.
One is up on me.
If you peek me, I can heal you.
What?
To my right.
Guys, no one is holding right side.
I couldn't.
I had to back up.
I got one.
But I'm knocked.
I got knocked too.
They might rest.
One point.
Fuck.
He's low.
It's fine.
I rest myself.
Playtime.
Dude, he's so fucking...
Don't peek me, bitch.
No peeking.
No peeking me.
Alright.
There's issues in the brain.
Why do you play better when you speak Russian English?
What talking?
What talking about?
No peeking me.
You die!
Joke's over.
If you guys want to peek me, I can flash this.
I'm looking right now.
No one made it.
I have a feeling they're rushing me.
Yeah, no one made it.
I'm going behind.
He's in the visibility wall.
I'm heading over.
They're all in the LZ.
They're floating thing.
Oh yeah, they are.
They are across.
They got me wallhacking.
They're smoking me.
They're smoking.
What the fuck?
He's here.
He's cheating wallhack.
On my body.
Wait, wait.
No.
I don't see anybody.
Got one.
We're not right now.
We're not right.
They smoked me.
He's pushing.
I don't know if I can help.
I knew they would push me like that.
Oh, I traded.
I traded.
I don't know.
It was not worth it though.
One v4.
This is clutch.
Oh, not clutch.
Guys, lock in.
Lock in.
We're trying.
We're trying our best.
They might push A now that they know that.
They're not going to do that again.
How do you ping in this game?
Z.
I mean you can re-bind it.
They fucking...
They take this fucking lift for free every time.
So I might just play right here.
But someone has to watch like mid-A.
If...
I'm watching here.
So if they are pushing, I'm going to look down.
But I have a shotgun.
So...
I can't do much.
But...
If they are pushing A, just like play that corner.
They might push A again because they realized it wasn't an easy take.
I don't see anyone mid.
Oh yeah, they are going A.
Going A.
There is one mid.
I've been spotted.
Fucking hell.
She's one.
I think she's...
Did I kill her?
There's two more.
I'm dead.
I can get revive, no?
No, no.
You're way too far.
He pushed out and ate me.
I'm looking right now.
I pinged for you.
One right here.
I see him.
Yeah, yeah.
I see the rotate.
They are going back.
My turret is still there, so...
Yeah, they are going hard B.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Careful, careful next.
I'm running for my life.
I think they are going B long.
Yeah, yeah.
All of them.
The sniper is looking at me.
One mid.
I'm flashing them.
Careful next.
Oh, they smoked me.
They smoked me, so I can't see anymore.
I'm backing out.
They are going to go for a normal bomb plant.
Careful, careful.
Yeah, yeah.
They are going dirt.
They are planting.
Nice.
Bomb down.
I'm healing you, Doki.
Behind, behind.
Right here, right here.
There is one over here.
She is low.
She is so low.
On point as well.
That girl is low, but she has armor.
He is planting.
What is he doing?
He is bad.
He is bad at the video game.
Share power.
Got them both.
Yeah!
What the fuck is happening?
I didn't realize my ult, I can just do it worldwide.
So I can rest Archer that whole time.
Nice.
Did you even use your res?
No.
Guys, I think shotgun will...
Guys, 4000 damage.
Hey, 4500.
We broke 3k.
We broke 3k, guys.
I'm the only person in this team who has gotten an MVP.
What?
No, I got the...
You got S, VP.
Shotgun guy was mistake.
It's okay, we carried you.
That's okay.
Yeah, but I carried attack.
I carried attack.
We did it!
We won a game, guys!
We won a game.
Look at us!
Oh my god!
We are not that bad!
You guys have won.
Congratulations.
Yay!
Thank you!
Yeah!
I feel like this was like the battle of the mids.
I wish we were in group B.
We should have been in group B, guys.
It was the mid of the year.
Hey, 1W, I take it.
Yay, guys!
I'm proud of all of us.
We did not get stomped.
Except that one time.
No, we don't talk about that.
I was MVP of that game.
You want me to MVP of the game when you got stomped?
Which means I am most performing.
Alright.
GG's, guys.
I had a great time.
I have to go prep for my...
I have to go prep for my debut stuff.
I had a great time.
GG's.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
When we do this again.
We win.
GG's.
Okay, we're not gonna win against that.
We win the tournament tomorrow.
The team with the 9-0.
We warmed up.
GG's, guys.
GG's.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye, Adamin.
Alright, everybody.
Okay, I have like an hour and a half to fully prep for the model day.
Skinsuit day.
Oh my gosh.
Stranova is fucking me up.
Skinsuit debut.
My version!
Because I'm gonna be a model.
That's why I said model debut.
Anyway.
Anyway, guys.
I am going to go prep now.
We won our one game, chat.
We won one game out of three.
That's all that matters.
One out of three.
Anyway, guys.
I am going to head off now.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, stay up a little longer.
Because I have the Skinsuit reveal in an hour and a half!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!